good morning the S.
Senate the Senate committee on
elections and constitutional
amendments will come to order
in response to cobit nineteen
response the covert nineteen
emergency and to protect the
public legislators employees
we must limit nonessential
gatherings and it here to
social distancing and face
covering guidelines in
compliance with these orders
the Senate has made necessary
adjustments to normal practices
in order to ensure that the
public continues to have access
to the legislative process
we are holding our committee
hearings here in the capital
to allow for public access
we've admitted members of the
public into the hearing room
to the extent that social
distancing requirements allow
and we will also be using
the teleconference Orvis
for those individuals who
wish to testify today for
all individuals wishing to
provide public comment the
dissident toll free number and
access code are posted on our
Committee website and it will
be displayed on the screen
and I will announce it now
today's participant number is
eight four four two nine one
five four nine zero and the
access code is five one seven
one six nine seven for detailed
instructions on how the
teleconferences to works please
refer to the Senate and are
Committee website when we moved
to public comment you'll be
prompted by a moderator to dial
one and then zero four support
and opposition press this only
one time and wait patiently for
an operator to assign you to a
line number this can be a short
wait once you receive your line
number you'll wait in the queue
for the moderator to call your
line number at that time you'll
be on mute it and you're now
ready to address the committee
please note that in order
for us to hear you clearly
and avoid acoustic feedback
you must mute the device
you're watching the hearing
on prior to giving testimony
over the phone it's important
that we hear from you and we
thank you for your patience I
will maintain decorum during
the hearing as is customary
and any individual who is
destructive may be removed from
the remote median service or
have their connections muted
while every effort has been
made to streamline the hearing
process and conduct our
hearings in as close to the
same manner as is customary
there may be some lag times
for participants were adjusting
to the new use of online
tools or technologies please
be respectful and patient so
all interested parties can
be heard we have six bills on
the agenda today in earlier
agenda released on Thursday
listed seven bills but SB
two eighty six by senator
man was pulled from today's
hearing at the author's request
generally bills are heard
and -- author order however I
will be presenting my bill at
the end of the agenda today
to allow senator Newman to
present his bills first before
we hear presentations on the
bills let's establish a quorum
consultant please call the roll
thank you tears reminder
please make sure to turn your
microphone on and speak into
the microphone Glazer here
Glazer here Nielsen Nielsen
Hertzberg
Leyva here they were here
Newman Newman here all right we
do have a quorum I understand
that senators Nielsen and
Hertzberg will be arriving
later this morning and we
will put all bills on call so
they can participate as they
see fit we do have one item
on the consent calendar SB
five ninety four is there a
motion on the consent calendar
center Leyva has moved the
consent calendar consulting
would you please call the roll
for SB five nine four
on the consent calendar
Glazer hi Glazer hi Nielsen
Hertzberg Leyva I live up by
Newman all right Newman hi all
right that still enjoys three
votes and we're going to put it
on call for absent members due
to the constraints regarding
the length of hearings and
technology considerations and
cleaning protocols -- I have
the right to limit testimony --
today I certainly each side is
going to be permitted an equal
amount of time after today's
hearing each side is permitted
one or two lead witnesses who
may speak for a combined time
of three minutes -- decided
as they prefer all the others
wishing to testify must limit
their comments to their name
affiliation and position on the
measure I'm also go again and
that and that after to provide
equity I'm gonna provide twenty
minutes of testimony for each
side -- as we go through these
bills so three minutes combined
for your lead witnesses and
twenty minutes in total after
each side in support and
opposition of the bills that
will here today I want to
welcome senator Newman you have
for bills on art the gender
today and if that's okay with
you will start with us before
for two -- and welcome you to
a to present thank you Mister
chair -- Committee let me get
my so to give him an F.
and I will be doing this
from the day since we
don't yet have the podium
through a guests were
probably saving up for that
-- all right
yeah good morning Mister
chair and senators -- I'm here
before you today to prison as
before for to a bill that will
ensure the California school
districts are able to smoothly
make a transition from at large
elections to district based
elections without incurring the
cost and delays of California
voting rights act lawsuits
during that process since
the passage of the California
voting rights act in two
thousand one to promote greater
representation and equity
elections more than two hundred
of California's one thousand
thirty seven school districts
have since switched from at
large elections to district
based systems for the election
of trustees in recent years
it has been the consistent
policy of both is the of
this legislation to encourage
political subdivisions to
adopt district based elections
while giving to simplify the
process for doing so toward
that end California education
code section five zero one
nine currently allows County
committees that oversee the
organizations school districts
to establish trustee area
elections in a prompt and
inclusive process unfortunately
as a result of an Akron isn't
and state law school districts
governed by a board of
education provided for as part
of the charter of the city or
county are not entitled to the
same process and are instead
required to put any ordinance
on establishing trust your
trust year elections to the
electors of the district which
is a burdensome requirements
often results in the need to
hold in to pay for an official
election in practice school
districts and bypass the
stature requirement by securing
a waiver from the state board
of education this extra step
however still adds time an
additional cost to the adoption
of trustee -- elections with
the unfortunate and ironic
result that socialists have
actually resulted in the
holding of such an at large
elections which are found to be
in violation of the California
voting rights act simply
put these unnecessary and
unproductive complexities can
result in costly litigation and
subsequent unlawful at large
elections that perpetuate the
dilution of minority voters in
violation of either the spirit
or the letter of the CVR ag
SB four four two fixes this
problem by allowing ordinances
approving a proposed and to
establish trustee areas to
take effect immediately upon
adoption without the need
for an additional election
to affirm approval under
the terms of the bill is
provisions would apply to all
elections for governing board
members more than one hundred
twenty five days following
its chapter and I'd like to
thank the committee staff for
their hard work in calibrating
fine tuning its terms in the
language governing them and I
will be accepting amendments
recommended by the committee
that reconcile the bill was
School District which you've
already created independent
redistricting commissions for
the purpose of transitioning to
district elections with these
changes incorporated S.
before for two will go far in
streamlining the transition
process for the election
school district trustees
while eliminating delays and
additional costs borne by
taxpayers resulting from delays
and prospective litigation
this bill is supported by
the California teachers
association the southwest
voter registration education
project and currently has
no formal opposition with me
today virtually is Michelle
Warshaw from the California
department of education to
answer any technical questions
with respect to the provisions
of the law I am respectfully
requesting your aye vote today
thank you us center Newman
and -- Michelle Warsaw's I
understand is on the line for
technical questions as you so
indicate so we don't have any
lead witnesses on this bill
so we're going to -- go to --
witnesses here in thirty one
ninety one is the one which
has to find favor of this
legislation out see now we're
gonna go to the teleconference
line moderator would you
please prop any individual
who wish to testify in support
of SB four four two -- to so
indicate so we can hear the
testimony Care thank you if
you would like to testify
to SB four four two please
press one zero at this time
in eighteen Chaparro access
your line in place you back in
so you know your line number
again if you'd like to testify
in support of SB four two
please press one zero at this
time four four two skews me
yeah
and again I to testify
in support of SB four
four two please press
one zero at this time
nobody is queuing up at this
time thank you moderator
we're now going globally
we get we did just get a
couple arguing out so it
I apologize is
there was the operator one
second Probody outgoing it one
zero if you'd like to testify
in support of SB four four two
one one issue with this anymore
we'll go to line eighty
five please go ahead
members of the committee Tony
trigger -- on behalf of the
California teachers association
in support thank you thank
you thanks caller operator
thank you there are no other
participants queued up at this
time Mister chair terrific
thank you very much let's move
to witnesses in opposition
to SB for for two other is
there anyone here in that
room thirty one ninety one in
opposition xenon we're gonna
go to the teleconference line
moderator would you ask if
anyone wishes to testify in
opposition to SB four four
two to please so indicate
that's why in opposition
of SB four four two please
press one followed by zero
at this time one call by
zero to testify in opposition
to SB four four hello
nobody is giving up okay
would raise somebody's
queuing up point right
now sorry this is S.
B. four four two in
opposition go ahead either
it was
and we will line twenty
eight please go ahead
we met in opposition your
County thank you very
much next caller operator
Mister chair than other
participants queued up at
this time okay want to thank
those who have testified in
support and opposition --
we're going to bring the matter
back to the committee for
discussion questions members
any comments or questions
Leyva thank you Mister chair
I just want to thank the
author for bringing it forward
I think this is sometimes a
big contentious point when
school districts do want to
go from being at large to
district so it's creating a
streamlined process up and
on the street stated he was a
great idea and all of the bill
of hope appropriate could any
other comments or questions
from members welcome center
Nielsen here nice to see you
Sir all right I also I join my
colleague and and expressing my
appreciation to the author for
bringing this bill forward it
seems like it's a pragmatic and
constructive for a change in
happy to support it today I'm
gonna recognize -- I guess we
have a opportunity to close an
urgent you know Judge close I
appreciate that I would I would
respectfully ask when I vote
this morning thank you center
in a recognized motion for the
center Leyva this is a -- do
pass as amended the author did
accept the amendments proposed
by the committee of the first
that'd be amended and re refer
to the committee on education
we are we have a wonderful
chair here -- in the room so
with that motion -- -- console
would you please call the roll
press before for to the motion
is to pass as amended the first
amended and referred to the
committee on education Glazer
aye Glazer hi Nielsen Nielsen
by Hertzberg Leyva all right
Leyva aye Newman aye Newman
aye right that bill has four
votes we're going to hold the
role open for an absent number
thank you senator Newman for
that presentation we're going
to keep you in the -- the hot
spot here in the spotlight and
ask if you would that present
SB five eighty three -- thank
you lord is yours thank you
Mister chair as part of my
bag full of bills this morning
AB Mister chair and members
-- I am here before that he
advocated be have SB five
eight three which will build
out and implement a backend
automatic voter registration
system at the California
department of vehicles and
other relevant state agencies
thereby taking the next logical
step forward on expanding
voter registration California
to safely effectively and
accurately include as many
eligible Californians possible
in our democratic process
implementing backend AV R.
as it is known will build
on California's successful
implementation of the new
motor voter system to create
a more efficient effective and
secure process for registering
new voters updating existing
registrations and protecting
noncitizens Colorado Oregon
Alaska and Massachusetts of all
passed legislation to embrace
and implement back in every our
intifada has a similar model
under California's current hard
stop voter registration DMV
customers are asked a yes or
no registration question during
the DMV's current flow during
typical DMV transactions such
as applying for or renewing a
license or ID card at present
despite the relative ease the
motor voter large numbers of
Californians opt to decline
to register to vote or to
update their voter registration
records for a range of reasons
which include one they arrived
to believe they're already
registered to vote or that
their voter registration is
already up to date second they
may be in a rush to leave the
DMV and fully intend to do so
later -- but failed to do so at
a later time third that they're
confused or unsure of their
current rights and options with
respect to both a registration
this is a particular problem
for formerly incarcerated
individuals as well as for
sixteen and seventeen year
olds who are now eligible
for pre reg registration as
a result of recent changes
in California law this so
called hard stop system leads
to close to fifty percent of
DMV customers declining voter
registration the net result
of that roughly four million
yeah direct net result is
that roughly four million
eligible Californians failed
to register to vote despite
being fully qualified to do so
in a do Chen and perhaps more
problematically the current
system fails to catch an update
millions of voter registration
records that contain out of
date information creating
problems further down the line
when it comes to voting SB
five eight three would plug
these current leaks in the
information pipeline a person
who is not currently registered
to vote but who provides proof
of US citizenship such as a
passport or birth certificate
during a do you the transaction
would automatically have
their information passed
to the secretary of state
for registration to include
associating any language
preference expressed during
the DMV transactions county
registrars within receive
notice with the information
for the new voter county
registrar's offices within mail
these new registrants a multi
lingual notice offering the
chance to decline registration
as well as the option of
choosing a party affiliation
selecting or changing their
language preference or
receiving a ballot by mail the
person could then return this
notice on a prepaid postage
basis as well as make any
changes online in Colorado
which is currently employing
a back and if your system
similar to the one being
proposed here in contrast to
the roughly forty five percent
of Californians who declined
to register under our current
implementation of motor voter
only one percent of Coloradans
to receive mail notices decline
registration at the same time
since its implementation of
back and if you are Colorado
DMV transaction times have
been reduced as well by up
to seventy five seconds per
customer in the last review
it's worth noting that the
California department of motor
vehicles is already collecting
and recording information
with respect to the type of
identity documents a person
provides an automated back in
system like those state like
states like Colorado uses
would simply leverages on
going work flow to ascertain
eligibility enrollment for
voting in a more streamlined
and secure way as noted
implementing back in eighty
are would also streamlined
registration updates if an
existing registered voter
provides an address your name
to the DMV that differs from
registration records the DMV
would then automatically for
that change of information
to elected officials for
updating in their records the
voter would then receive a
notice by mail of the change
to include the opportunity to
make any additional updates
or corrections because someone
registered voters may not
provide proof of citizenship
during certain DMV transactions
the provisions of SB five
eight three would maintain the
current motor voter system for
unregistered people who do not
provide proof of US citizenship
ship during DMV transactions
and to ensure appropriate
protections for non citizens
the back in AB are system would
automatically filter out DMV
customers who have provided
documents establishing foreign
citizenship such as a green
card applicants for an AB sixty
license these DMV customers
would not be offered the chance
to register and would not have
any of their information passed
on by the system to election
officials by contrast the
current system offers all DMV
customers the opportunity to
register to vote even if they
have provided proof of provided
proof of non citizenship as
part of their transaction
this quirk of the current
system exposes non citizens
to a needless trap if they
make a mistake when faced with
citizenship and registration
questions as a result in
attention confusion or of
limited English proficiency
they can inadvertently expose
themselves to potentially
catastrophic criminal and
immigration consequences
finally recognizing that the
DMV does not reach all eligible
voters the bill would give
the sector State the authority
to extend back in AB are to
other state agencies that
procedurally verify U. S.
citizenship as part of standard
agency transactions as is the
case with medi cal enrollment
program run by DH CS the
implementation back in AB are
proposed by SB five eight three
offers a range of benefits
and improvements compared to
the current system to include
an easier more streamlined
workflow for the DMV safely
and accurately expanding
the number of registered
California voters ensuring
a more diverse electorate
is appropriate reflective
of California's diverse and
dynamic population continually
updating records enabling more
accurate voter registration
databases thereby reducing
work by County registrar
offices enhance protections
for non citizens against
unintentional or run his voter
registration substantial labor
and cost savings over time for
the DMV the better and more
efficiently enabling rights
restoration for formerly
incarcerated Californians who
are eligible to vote but may
not be so aware over the past
decade California has made
great strides in engaging its
citizens in removing barriers
to political participation
and we can be proud to see
that reflected both in the
historically high rates of
turnout by California voters in
most recent round of elections
as well as the continued
trencher diversely in more
proportional representation
of women and people and of
color at every level of elected
governing bodies in our great
state SB five eight three
represents the next logical
step in that process with me
virtually to testify today I
just of the level of from the
coalition of humane immigrant
rights to discuss the on the
ground issues created by the
current system and Neil or
beyond from the center for
secure and modern elections to
answer any technical questions
regarding bill language I would
like to finish by stating that
I am committed to continue
to work collaborate with all
stakeholders and state agencies
as we move this bill through
the legislative process I
respectfully request your aye
vote today thank you senator
Newman -- we're now going to
move on to those who wish to
testify in support I understand
you have a primary witness in
support Joseph the Ella for the
coalition for humane immigrant
rights and so will ask the
moderators to open up his line
so we can hear his testimony
and if you're there to testify
your line should be open just
go ahead and move yourself
thank you -- good morning I
can't I members my name is
Joseph have you got a policy
check back here let the
coalition for humane immigrant
right we are statewide
membership organization with
national impact we are here
about but Bonta A.
B. by eighty three which
will provide an automatic
voter registration them and
it's much safer or not that
that thank like when your
current that that California
currently currently has a
hard stop AB ours that they
mean which the N.
B. customers what black for
life and other than AB if I
were like that my answer to
question one I get that it's
been into you want to register
to vote not that there's
will have limited proficiency
but understand this question
the time allows fearful of
government interaction and
can get tripped during that
stressful transaction they
can't will correctly a path
to citizenship and register
to vote through example human
error without some of these
issues when that system was
implemented in twenty eighteen
my organization CHIRLA work
closely with secretary of
state and department of justice
by Dennis by an address this
problem I know we have only
had the phone and this there
for a few years back to back
in this then will increase
voter registration and better
protect not that that by
relying on documentation as
much as possible I can AB
are limit their rate of human
error with the back and it
give me the customer will
present a document published
and not their extension like
a daca student or green card
holder it's not a medically
filter out a lot of voter
registration that that person
is not offered the opportunity
to make a mistake that can have
a catastrophic consequence I'm
not a part of executives that
the market is thank protect
that that those from apple came
in Eric and as much as possible
after all this leaders will
respectfully ask you support
but it's still thank you
thank you very much and is
that Mr the LF as I understand
it that Mr -- -- Riady is
there for technical question
Sir it is running you want
to add before we go to
other witnesses in support
yes if I could just say --
good morning Care members my
name is nearly brownie on the
policy director at the center
for security model actions
yes to me it is a national
non partisan campaign support
states in making elections more
secure acceptable efficiency
I'm here in support of SB
five eighty three which as
mentioned upgrade California's
automatic voter registration
system to a back end system I
don't use an organ in Colorado
and several other states I
went and looked at some of
the benefits of back in AB
are over California's current
system first back and if you're
registered more people I will
roughly forty five percent
of the and the customers are
declining registration under
California's current system
declination rates for back
in mailers in Colorado or one
percent actually there are
also help overruled better
reflect California's diverse
citizenry in Oregon back in
AB are registered younger
less white and lower income
voters left out by traditional
voter registration methods
second back into your create
more accurate registration
records automatically updating
Anderson information records
at the DMV I can't registration
records save time and money
by preventing undeliverable
mail including mail ballot and
reducing time spent updating
information polls third second
AB are relied on existing data
collection at the DMV provide
a more efficient system already
records the identity documents
provided your life transaction
back into your leverages
existing data collection to
streamline and improve the
efficacy of motor voter for
these reasons we respectfully
ask your support SB five
thank you I thank you very much
the supporters time did go a
little over will make sure that
the opposition side has equal
amount of time -- to provide
their testimony so we are gonna
now go for other witnesses who
would like to speak -- in our
and identify themselves as in
favor and -- now that we've
completed the lead testimony
we ask that you just give your
name your affiliation in your
support for this bill so we're
going to begin in room thirty
one ninety one is or anyone
here that would like to speak
-- identify themselves in
support of SB five eighty three
I'd seen that are gonna go
to the teleconference line --
moderator can you ask if there
are please prop any individual
with who wishes to testify in
support of SB five eighty three
thank you if you would like
to testify in support of Bill
five eighty three please press
one followed by zero at this
time one followed by zero
and our first question our
first a person will be by one
fifty seven please call at
probably a co sponsor
of this bill thank you
and next we'll go to line one
hundred sixteen you are open
hi my name is anymore and
I'm with the Orange County
Asian and Pacific Islander
community online and we
are in the south thank you
moving along we will live one
twenty five please go ahead
hi my name is Amy I'm with
the Chinese class of a thirty
Xin entrances at the port
dispel SB five eighty three
thank you next we'll go to
line sixty four you are open
hello my name is John
order that I think you
thank you one one hundred
sixty two please go ahead
good morning my name is Tom I'm
calling from eight eight the
act of an apartment in support
and as a final reminder please
press one zero to show your
support for SB five eight
three and we will go to
line ninety please go ahead
I thank Michael gonna Daly
from Eminem kind United calling
in support of SB five eight
and Mister chair there are
no other participants queued
up at this time thank you
moderator can you one last
-- call for anyone who wish
to support -- to so indicate
given one last chance year SB
five eighty three in support
of course the final reminder
please press one zero
for SB five eight three
please press one zero four
five eight three and we
do have one cued up please
moment
and we will I one hundred
sixty six please go ahead
hi my name is Tina McKenna
-- I am if it can get Eggman
director per LA Voigts and LA
quite action in Los Angeles
and I give my support SB
five eighty three thank you
Mister chairman no other
participants queued up at this
time terrific thank you very
much so we're now going to
go to opposition to this bill
I understand there's a lead
opposition witness Rosalyn
gold who is the public policy
officer for the national
association of Latino elected
and appointed officials --
ms gold here on the line --
you're welcome to like provide
your lead opposition testimony
-- to be fair you have three
minutes and fifteen seconds to
provide that and we welcome you
our great good morning I
chaired the laser Care by
turn Yeltsin another committee
members on Rockwell Goldman
chief public policy officer
I've been away -- educational
fun and I want to thank
you for this opportunity to
raise some questions about SB
five eighty three I want to
clarify that our organization
neither supports nor opposes
this legislation the where
are not unofficial opposer
we just would like to urge
the committee to carefully
examine certain questions we
have about the legislation
we also acknowledge and
appreciate the leadership of
senator Newman and all of the
proponent of that the H.
ID eighty three in working
to make voter registration
accessible to all Californians
because we share that important
call so the first question
we have is whether the
significant changes that SB
five eighty three you would
make the current new motor
voter program in terms of
making determinations about
whether certain documents show
citizenship are non citizenship
will indeed be more protective
than the current multi step
Act has station process that
is use our folks have talked
about human error but when you
have to design a new systems
automated new system train
people -- come up with a new
way of doing things there are
certainly also -- opportunities
and -- possibilities of human
error there so we question
what kind of testing what kind
of training -- what kind of
are really serious quality
assurance is going to be done
in creating that the automated
system that is going to -- you
know use documents to determine
Abu would automatically be
put on the voter rolls I will
also note that at this time
you know California is facing
some serious investments that
I have to make the deal with
cold at nineteen -- in terms
of our housing education health
payer economic development
and employment opportunities
and we question whether we are
going to get an appreciable
increase in voter registration
from the investment that is
going to be needed -- for --
the new system -- you know we
know some other states have
been sighted but these are
state that have very different
populations in California in
terms of their diversity --
and -- we also wonder whether
if indeed the issue of people
declining to register in front
and might be addressed by some
kind of education or better
clarification in the current
system rather than putting all
of these resources in a new
automated or some other kind
of system based on documents --
there are some other features
of the proposed SB five eighty
three system that we have
questions about we put this
into a letter -- for example
it doesn't appear to capture
up front the political party
or vote by mail preference of
the voters -- -- these people
indicate those preferences
would have to stand in and
respond tool for that they
get in the mail and -- we have
seen at least in Oregon there's
not always people who answer
the question or send that form
back -- and we have similar
questions about the way that
our language preference for
voting material is collected
in school you can ultimately
-- again we want to emphasize
that we very much respect and
appreciate the commitment of
senator Newman and SB five
eighty three proponents Lake
photo registration acceptable
to all Californians Abu
share that goal but we really
also urge this committee to
carefully examine the thank
you and we have raised in our
capital thank you thank you
miss school for that -- we're
gonna look for other witnesses
that wish to put their name
on the record in opposition
to SB five eighty three --
operator would you ask if
there's anyone who wishes to
do that on the phone lines
thank you if you would like
to testify please press one
followed by zero at this time
and we will go to line one
sixty seven please go ahead
hi I think they tried to get
through and during the time but
and the political sector Asian
Pacific environmental network
and then actually in court
three okay thank you very much
for everybody else that is
in opposition to the SP five
eight three please press one
followed by zero at this time
and we will go to line one
hundred fourteen he's got that
yes one fourteen
you're you're open
one fourteen
would you like to testify
open run we'll go to line
one seventy three please go
ahead Sally Jones I'm from
grass valley California and
I oppose -- SB six six three
right this is five eight three
SB five eight three operator
he please -- invite anyone
else who wishes to testify
in opposition to five eight
three SB five eight three
thank you to testify in
opposition to five eight three
please press one zero and we
were line one seventy three
where you have a few more
killing up one moment please
we will align one seventy one
seventy I would like I would
like to strongly oppose the
bill because of the breach of
voter privacy and the potential
for voters this is -- SB five
eight thank you thank you for
calling in and reminder that
this is as five eight three
there's a variety of different
bills by senator Newman on our
agenda no sorry I'm calling on
SB six six very sell -- will
record that for the future
thank you very much operator
can you really appreciate it
thank you queue up the next
caller in opposition to SB five
eight three absolutely please
press one followed by zero and
we will This Is again ladies
on for SB five eight three in
opposition and we will I one
zero nine yeah hi my name is
David Custer and send you a
County and I'm opposed to SB
five eight three thank you Sir
and we'll go to line one
seventy please go ahead
Oakland police close we'll
go to line one seventy nine
please go ahead yes I wanted
to call to let you know that I
oppose six six three D.
and all right well underground
that that matter the bill's
coming up in a few minutes
but we're dealing with five
eight three five eight three
SB five eight three right
now so moderate would you
go to the next caller please
yes absolutely I will I am one
sixty eight please go ahead
Justin masters in Roseville
California I am opposed
to Senate Bill five
eight three thank you
annex three going to one
moment please more doing up
moderator anyone else
-- queued up to -- give
their testimony opposition
to SB five eight three
we lose our moderator
there no they are queuing
up one moment please the
operators having problems
with security could sex now
we were line seventy four
please go ahead seventy four
yes they required from San
Bruno counting in opposition
opposition for SB five
eighty three thank you Sir
thank you I will put next we'll
move on to line one eighteen
in
California and I'm opposed to
this bill thank you very much
why Christy to please go ahead
yes my name only jail
house from yolo county
California and I oppose SB
five eighty three thank you
one moment please
and we have a one sixty
seven you are open Kern
Kirsten opposing SB five
eight three thank you
next I will go to
line twenty eight
we met very plaster in
opposition thank you
why one eight excuse me
one eighty two you are open
I one eighty two please go
ahead hello that is that me
yeah I am a better Garcia
from better County I oppose
this bill thank you hi one
forty eight please go ahead
we can hear you guys
again hello I'm I am
SB five eighty three
thank you
line one twenty
four you are open
I Valerie Appelbaum from
Lafayette California and aye
opposed at eight five eight
three thank you thank you
we were line one zero
one please go ahead hi my
name is Patrick San Diego
county and I oppose SB
five eight three thank you
annex was line one
seventy one you are out
hi my name is merry along
Glenn Murray I want from Santa
Clara county aye opposed SB
five eight three thank you
why one ninety two
please go ahead
one ninety two that
is yeah you were on
what
three all people are being
denied entrance okay right
now well doing okay well we
totaling one forty you
in a moment there's a lot
of excitement about some
future bills on our agenda
today we'll get to them in
just a few but we are SB
five eight thirty right now
S. wine one forty
eighth please go ahead
moderator anyone further
to testify in opposition
to five eight three
we appreciate everyone's
patience as we go through
these -- these bills that
technology is wonderful and
it's challenging under our code
rules to make sure everybody
can be heard but that's our
goal here today so we want
to ask people for their
patience both in favor and
in opposition to five eight
three will give both a chance
to -- but to make sure their
testimonies on the record
so moderate anyone else you
Mister chair I am back thank
you all I'm sorry I watched
my voice line for second but
I am back thank you so much
our guys and we will go to one
thirty five please go ahead
nine thirty five can you hear
us one thirty five yeah I'm
here thirty five can you hear
me we can hear you fine --
ahead hello okay this is Gloria
Mackey now been turret county
and I'm opposed to SB five
eight three thank you thank
you all and we will go to one
sixty nine please go ahead
hi this is one of the factors
found with the bill -- County
aye opposed SB five eight three
thank you thank you
twenty one seventy
seven you are open
one seventy seven commuters
five eight three
thank you my one seventy
nine please go ahead yes I
oppose five eight three I am
powering Turner Montesa renal
Google one one eighty
four please go ahead
hello twenty four yes -- okay
this is Sandra Marquez and
I am from potter county and
I am calling to at six six
three okay and I would like
to ask our representative your
bill that bill will come up
-- in a few minutes The bill
come up in a few minutes --
what were you doing with SB
five eight okay so moderated
you ask does anybody else
think you in opposition to
SB five eight three reminding
everyone that we don't again
yeah please please only queue
up at this time if you're in
opposition the SB five eight
three take yourself aren't you
by getting one zero again at
three we opposed by anything
okay I will go one ninety
two please go ahead at all
look at yes you
are ma'am your yes
I mean the building
being -- Eder
you can please go ahead
yes my name is Ryan Shotton
from Ventura county California
and I vote against SB five
eighty three great thank
you very much and moderator
if someone is destructive
again would you please that
cut the line off and I'll go
to my right away okay sorry
about that I would just want
to make sure it okay they're
gonna they're testifying big
government bill will give them
an opportunity at that time
absolutely thank you Mister
chair and will align one --
one ninety two please go ahead
under
buying two hundred
please go ahead
we'll go to line
with thirty seven
Rubio yeah this is Stephanie
Rubio Orange County and aye
opposed by deeply thank you
and we'll go to line one
fifty nine you are open
yes my age they have
to stand out of plaster
county I'm opposed to this
bill thank you thank you
one forty nine please go ahead
yes I have not and -- indigo
California and I am opposed
SB five eighty three thank you
why one sixty four you are open
-- hi all my name is Kate Kate
when you go from Common Prayer
Connie and I hold on SB five
eight three thank you thank
you very much for your patience
why one hundred eighty
eight please go ahead
it took themselves out of Q.
and we'll go to line two
hundred please go ahead
two two hundred you are open
and Mister Kerr one
moment please --
Ste
try to go line forty five
please go ahead I opposed five
eighty three Carol Buckland
thank you
hello thanks to a line two
hundred please go ahead
two hundred to come so sorry Q.
AB I apologize -- research
I think the operator that
sticking the line numbers
as having just a little bit
of problems here one second
please I do understand that
we're having some technical
issues -- that also if folks
who wanted to speak in support
of -- five eighty three also
had difficulty self we're
gonna finish up with those in
opposition will give those who
want to put their name on the
record in support opportunity
want one more time to what
to do so but let's go ahead
and finish with the those who
want to put their name and
affiliation on the record in
opposition to SB five eighty
three to please so indicate
an operator please continue
to invite them to our okay
so I've been SB five eight
three is one zero and
we were like two hundred
twenty four please go ahead
your
way to twenty four you are
open I'm I'm waiting to be
done a different bill I've
already uploaded great and he
what yes okay thank you long
we are going to go to find
fifty four please go ahead
San Luis Obispo county
aye opposed SB five
eight three thank you
one one fifty two please go
ahead hi Bob Hertzberg county
Ohio pulled behind the decrease
one forty eight your up
yes that you please go
ahead I would give my name
correctly I'm Cindy she a
Santa Clara county and I
oppose SB five eighty three
Alex conservative politics
so speak fast please thank
by two hundred please go ahead
those out let's go to line
to fourteen you are open
yes my name is Kelly
Steinberger from
California and I'd like
thank you why do
you please go ahead
Myers after County
and I'm Colusa spell
and we'll go to line seventy
three you are open my name is
Linda rich from that of this
to California and I oppose
bill SB five eighty three
thank you one seventy
eight please go ahead
my name is Kim Scott I'm
calling from plaster county
and I SB five eighty three
thank you and we will go
to line one seventy two
please go ahead back up
on your Allen Ventura
County I oppose this bill
one two hundred you are open
I know one moment we have
one more up actually they
took themselves out to secure
their no other participants
queued up at this time
thank you moderator given
some technical issues and
at that time -- that we've a
lot it hasn't been exceeded
I want to go back to those
in support of SB five eighty
three give them an opportunity
put their name and affiliation
on the record in support of
the bill operative you ask
if there's anybody still
in queue in support of SB
five eighty three two SO
indicates a we could have their
testimony put on the record
please press one followed
by zero if you are support
of SB five eight three
we did get a couple more
queuing up one moment
okay two hundred again
night and not responding
I apologize still not well one
one zero two please go ahead
good morning my name is Lisa
did grow until Contra Costa
county aye opposed SB five
eighty three I within Q.
number one oh two okay thank
you for getting back in
and sharing that operator
please go forward thank
you Mister chair will go to
line one hundred and fifteen
yes this is Robert Brown
I live in the Yuba county
and I would like to express
support for Senate Bill
five eight three thank you
very much next caller please
one twenty your open -- hi this
is brandy the thing in Tamriel
California as well I am in
opposition I was in the queue
and I never got called by the
opposition and I it's all good
thank you very much for your
persistence all right the five
eight great thank you thank you
so much thank and next we'll go
to line one seventy six share
K. R. my neighbor Totoro backed
up beyond all I'm calling on
behalf of power California an
organization comprised of over
twenty five alliance members
all of them organizations and
communities are finding it
will County all the way on
all my county and I'm calling
in support from eighty five
eighty three are we know
that it is doing any good
I think that the typically
for those that we work with
we've already heard testimony
in favor and we appreciate
you putting your name on the
record in support as well
thank you thank you next caller
well god willing two hundred
thirty please go ahead hello
my name is Michelle and Carla
telling I -- reside in the
South Bay I'd like to voice
my opinion on SB six six three
I strongly well we're not
we're not hearing that bill
yet will be here in that bill
in a few minutes so please
stand by and we'll get to six
six three in a moment we'll
take some -- testimony in
favor of SB five eight three
five eight three so if you
want to indicate support for
that bill please so indicate
so we can get your name and
affiliation on the record This
Is SB five eight three five
I'm sorry I don't have that
information we'll move on to --
to thirty one please go ahead
Hey Melissa please check
your lotus number project
director for Orange County
environmental justice I just
want to -- became the core
and at but about thirty three
four in the run off election
about registration got it
thank you so much next caller
please moderator one moment
we'll go to line one hundred
eighty please go ahead
one hundred eighty you are open
and I know other participants
queued up at this time Mister
chair okay very good we thank
everyone for their patience
and support and in opposition
to this bill -- who of --
provided their testimony on
our teleconference lines --
we are going to now bring the
matter back to the committee
for further discussion and
quite -- and I will leave
it off given the absence of
some of my colleagues at the
moment senator Newman thank
you for of bringing this bill
forward at the goals that you
outline our goals that I'm a
hundred percent embrace week
you know we had an incredible
turn out of -- -- voters in
this last election and I think
it's something of of great
accomplishment in praise for
all the folks that are involved
in that the secretary of state
in the registrar's often down
the state of the we know and
you have been quite clear that
there are many others that
might want to participate and
we should do everything we
can to make that as easy and
as possible I think that's
the goal that you've outlined
in your bill -- and I fully
support it the only thing that
gives me some hesitancy -- in
this matter is that -- that
that the department of motor
vehicles is not have a great
track record -- unfortunately
-- through administration
staff past and present -- in
being able to take what are
a thoughtful measures such
as yours and making sure that
they're implemented -- fairly
-- and -- and completely
and yet we we have seen that
track record -- we also know
that what you're asking for
nay actually reduced -- --
personnel time -- and and
create some efficiencies but
it it comes as a requirement
that the technology the
technology has to be there
-- and that much of what you
-- is going to be required in
your bill is going to be some
improvements in that technology
and once again unfortunately
-- in state government we've
struggled in that space -- as
well -- and so that that's the
that's the thing that worries
me I I was hopeful that we
would have a representative
from the department of motor
vehicles here to provide their
thoughts and their testimony
and we have not had that we
reached out to them as well --
Committee is reach out to them
-- and we haven't gotten any
feedback on the operational
side I was also hoping that
we would have someone from the
secretary of state's office
here to participate in this
conversation -- today because
they are so important in making
sure that we dot all the I's
and cross all the keys to make
sure that the good -- goals
that you have outlined in your
bill -- can be operational
as well and unfortunately
they have not come forward to
provide their testimony we've
reached out to the office and
-- one of knowledge of course
the great leadership the new
leadership in that office --
by secretary of state Weber
and I certainly there's a lot
of start up -- obligations
that I'm sure they're they're
wrestling with and this is
one of many things that that
they have to focus on but we
haven't benefitted from their
their their input either and
so that really is the heart of
it for me is not the goals but
the ability to operationalize
-- what you are calling for
in your bill -- the timeline
that you've establishes pretty
aggressive -- and so that's
that's the part of it troubles
me as I offer year irrigation
on that that question -- if
you would all right -- thank
you Mister I I do appreciate
the questions it particularly I
think it's reasonable actually
obvious -- to have concerns
about DMV's prior track
records relates to technology
implementation I would
point out that the DMV is --
apparently making progress --
over the last year or so under
the governor's leadership --
taking some newer very urgent
projects to solving some of the
problems that come up but it
but it you know the the proof
is always in the doing with
respect to the implementation
of the technology we has a
state will actually in this
case have the benefit of
the prior experience of some
other states -- and and so I
think we can call on states
such as Colorado for some
insight -- and and and learn
from their experience but --
you know these things are
obviously challenging -- and
then again back to your point
with respect to timeline
state as I've made clear -- in
working with all the different
stakeholders we're open to it
-- you know deed I my office
the the sponsor the bill or
are open to appropriately
amending those time lines to
make sure that we don't get
ahead of our skis as they say
but all in I think it's fairly
clear especially based on the
experience of other states that
this is a workable scenario
-- and when fully implemented
it has the dual benefit of
increasing the efficiency of
the DMV -- but just in poorly
actually more importantly Sir
is that very admirable goal
of engaging a larger share of
the electorate when it comes
to opting into voting -- in
that will be to the good thank
you for for sharing that I
guess I don't two things one
is is that you know that there
have been successful tech
technological improvements
that state governments and
other places and I'll put it
on California is so big and
so vast and the obligations
or agencies -- so much more --
in the greater in scale that
unfortunately even when we've
seen successes and and the
implementation of technology
in other states -- it still has
remained a big challenge here
I think it's much for our size
and complexity as as anything
else I'm not certainly that
the good work of up all of the
-- State leaders and -- and
consultants that getting gauged
in these types of things and
so and fortunately even the
successes was you -- report
-- in other states doesn't
still gives me concern okay
-- but and here's the thing
at our elections have been
incredibly well run -- that
given the number of up of
-- voters that we have been
registered -- individuals --
you know it there is set so
much praise and appreciation
to our secretary of state
current and former as well
as the registrars across the
state that have conducted these
elections in an extraordinarily
effective and honest way
-- but we know that it when
you're when you have twenty
million people voting that
there's still going to be
some concerns and problems
and so yes as we look at the
landscape you know we do see
some examples of where someone
might have received a second
ballot -- and and and there are
little things and I I stress
how little they are in the
context of all that's going
on in our elections process
where -- inadvertent mistakes
have occurred and they raise
questions and with it makes
all of us uncomfortable when
those questions are raised
even as in as infinitesimally
small as they may be and so
and the reason that gives
us concerns is because the
integrity of our election
process is foundational to our
entire democracy we need people
to have confidence that --
everything that we do in regard
to a voter exercising their
choice is done above board
transparent and -- and fair
I I know it's the same goals
you have we all have because
it's so important to our our
governmental system that we
have and so once again while I
share the goals that you have
laid out in your bill it is the
confidence level that I think
we must have -- that is B.
as gives me pause in regard
to this bill now I appreciate
this is the first hearing and
-- that there is going to be
a lot of opportunities going
forward for user and you know
that your great leadership to
work through these questions
we hope that DMV and the
secretary of state -- and other
stakeholders will engage more
thoroughly as the bill gets
vetted but I would ask you to
arrive at it as this bill moves
forward and -- and I'm willing
to support it to move forward
that I ask you to -- to stay
connected to our committee
to stay connected to me and
to give me some confidence
going forward that that that
check and will enable us to if
necessary caught I don't call
for applause if it's necessary
if these questions have been
the result I know you want
to resolve them to and you're
very committed to having this
not just be implemented but to
work he wanted to work has your
name on it you wanted to have
pride and how it's been done
but I would ask you to give
me a little more confidence
and assurance that that that
this committee will have that
opportunity to join you --
in that level of confidence
all right with that at
any other members have any
questions or comments enter
Newman to go back to you for
clothes and perhaps you can
address those those issues in
your clients I I'd be glad to
Mister so so I I do appreciate
your concerns I I actually
share your concerns -- I will
wholeheartedly committed to
working with this committee
but be you again working with
all stakeholders it did these
are not simple questions to
solve your is Forest -- these
kinds of implementations I
do think it's worthy of I
would also point out that in
addition to the DMV's recent
progress that we as a state or
the the the the beneficiaries
of a whole bunch of really
impressive progress when it
got at the Secretary state
level -- in coordination with
all of the County registration
moving to the state wide voter
registration database which
was no small thing in its
own right so we have in the
sector states office a willing
partner -- a gan we have -- but
I think some good experience
drawn from other states that
is relevant -- not withstanding
California size but to your
point its original purpose to
implement a system that does
not work where that works
worse than its predecessor and
so I I share your concern I
will fully commit -- to work
with all stakeholders moving
forward and pulling The bill
back if necessary if we don't
have your insurance that we
can make that promise so with
that I asked respectfully for
an aye vote today so just to
clarify if you feel that this
committee feels that as the
bill moves forward it hasn't
been put in that that shape
to have that confidence on the
operational side that you will
bring it back to this committee
for further discussion to be
clear I would have been make
the commitment to reflect
okay -- any other comments or
questions for members -- we are
on SB five eighty three over
still there okay okay so we
have had a close and I'm now
looking for a motion on this
bill -- also moved okay the
Senate Health we have center
Leyva has -- stepped up in and
made a motion to -- to -- this
would be a do pass but first
to be referred to the committee
on rules as I understand it as
the status so indicate so with
that we do have a motion to
pass first referred referred to
the committee on rules of the
consulting with take the role
SB five eight three the motion
is due passed the first be
referred to the committee on
rules Glazer aye Glazer aye
Nielsen Hertzberg Leyva aye
waiver aye Newman all right
Newman all right okay that the
bill enjoys that the support of
three members we have to absent
and we'll wait to level for
the long call and wait for them
to join us later this morning
okay so we are going to move
on now to SB six six zero for
those people paying attention
at home -- this is six six
zero we have one more bill
by senator Newman after that
which is six six three but
we're going to focus right now
on this bill SB six six zero
senator Newman we welcome you
back to our community and we
would welcome your testimony
on this bill Mr sure it's good
to be back I feel like I was
never way -- and and I have the
this is a mixed blessing today
of having for bills some of
which have the same digits so
the last one had a three and it
would seem to get too confusing
because this has to six is --
but this bill is S.
B. six six zero -- and -- it
is very different than the bill
that will follow six X.
three Mister Sanders I am here
before today advocating on
behalf of SB six six zero under
its provisions by eliminating
common practices in gathering
signatures for ballot measures
which incentivize the willful
deception of voters SB six six
year will will make necessary
important steps towards
safeguarding the integrity
of California's initiative
referendum and recall process
sees California's one of
a number of states whose
constitutions expressly
provided citizens with tools
to directly redress abuses
of government or malfeasance
by public officials in the
form of the initiative the
referendum in the recall first
some historical background
and context if you may be
aware these admirable and
useful constitution director
Marcus you provisions date
back more than a century and
are the result of the efforts
of a group of progressive
reformers led by then governor
Hiram Johnson who then went
on to become California's
longest serving represented
the United States Senate
until -- with twenty eight
years in office until recently
being eclipsed by our own
senator Dianne Feinstein as a
result of the heroic efforts
of governor Johnson and
his supporters California's
constitution through the
initial referendum a recall
makes explicit provisions that
allow for the citizenry to take
actions outside of the normal
legislative process in order to
enact repeal legislation or to
remove a corrupt or malfeasance
elected official from office
but let me point out before
I get into the meat of this
this bill and its provisions
have nothing whatsoever to
do with the current effort to
recall are sitting governor
that has no urgency provision
-- and so it's passage will
have no impact at all on
that process let me go back
to built to the original
framers way of thinking the
initiative referendum and
recall represented a means
for the little guy to chief
directorate of and reformist
actions that elected invested
interest might otherwise thwart
because the framers of the
initial referendum a recall
regarding these processes as
populist actions of last resort
they deliberately provided
that in order to qualify for
the ballot the proponents
of any of these direct to
the voters plebiscites would
first be required to gather
a sufficient number of voter
signatures to validate the
legitimacy and popular support
for such an action over the
years and especially in recent
decades however something very
different than the framers
intent has transpired these
tools are Director moxie have
been effectively co opted by
the very money interest they
were originally created to
offset as these well funded
groups with it increasingly
explicit self interested
motivations have become
ever more adept at using the
initiative referendum and
recall process he's to their
benefit something of an arms
race around the processes
has ensued especially as it
pertains to signature gathering
at the center of these efforts
the small number of specialized
firms with expertise in
signature gathering have risen
to the fore offering their
services to proponents seeking
to place a measure on the
ballot and any given time one
of the principal tactics used
by the specialized things are
getting firms is the deployment
of well trained professional
signature gatherers typically
the signature gathers are
paid on a per signature or
commission basis also known as
a bounty at a rate determined
by the market as it is assessed
at that time depending on
the nature of the initiative
The characterised of the
district the time of year or
competition with other nations
either within the state or
in other states at that time
the cost procedure can vary
widely from as low as two
dollars per signature gathered
to as high as twenty dollars
in some cases and because
bounty paid signatures are
incentivized to optimize their
yield based on how rapidly
they can secure signatures from
voters they frequently traffic
and misdirection misleading
information and outright
falsehoods in order to reduce
as many voters as possible
to sign in the minimum out of
time thereby increasing their
yield against this backdrop
the determining factor getting
a measure on the ballot too
often has less to do with its
policy merits then the depth of
it's promote proponents pockets
of course this is exactly the
opposite of what the framers
originally had in mind as
the direct result of these
perverse incentives the paper
signature system has subverted
the original idealistic content
of California's founders
who envisioned a people
powered system of referenda
in propositions validated by
demonstrated public support
and would succeed or fail on
their merits not on what how
well the system can be gamed
the initiative referendum and
recall processes can and should
play an important value role
in California politics and
government this coming from
somebody who has been recall it
has become clear however that
under the current system driven
by persons you're bounties
there are scant prospects
for to turn bad actors who
willfully mislead voters at
the expense of the integrity
of the electoral process SB
six sixty addresses this issue
by prohibiting the practice of
paying signature gatherers on a
personal basis when collecting
signatures to place a state
or local initiative referendum
or recall on the ballot this
measure aye I should be clear
would not prohibit payment
for signature gathering that
is not based on the number of
signatures obtained Shigure
gathers still could be paid an
hourly wage or salary as the
proponents see fit this bill
will provide assurance and
transparency to the voters and
it's enforcement provisions
will permit both the Attorney
General and any person to
bring a civil claim under
this section for procedure
payment practices employers
which is to say those who
employs signature gathers who
violate the provisions of SB
six sixty would be subject to
a fine of twenty five thousand
dollars or fifty dollars per
signature fraudulent gathered
whichever amount is greater
if that is proving this
good government measure will
serve to strengthen a recall
referendum and issue processes
by ensuring that voters are
aware of exactly what they're
signing and are not being
deceived ultimately SB six
sixty will help to restore
faith in our elections and our
nation processes other states
such as Colorado Montana and
Oregon have already examined
the issues surrounding facing
she gathers and of adopted
legislation prohibiting
procedure about two payments
require that payment fishing
together make may only be made
on an hourly or a salary based
it is time for California to do
the same our democracy and our
governments and our politics
will be the better for it I
respectfully ask for your aye
vote today thank U.
S. senator Newman -- I
understand you don't have a
lead witness in support and
there are no lead with me
witnesses in opposition so
we're going to -- allow for
some discretion for the first
folks who -- when a testified
support opposition to provide
a little bit more -- to -- in
testimony to the committee so
let's go to those in thirty
one ninety one is anyone here
that wishes to testify in
support of SB six six zero
all right seen and we're
gonna go to the phone lines
-- moderator would you ask if
there is anyone on the phone
lines it would like to speak
in support of S. B.
six six zero and so indicating
we welcome them to our hearing
Glazer down again in support
of only SB six six zero
please press one zero at
this time and we were lying
twenty eight please go ahead
L. we have I think some
of these lines were frozen
from the last time so
give me one second I'm gonna
the fresh my screen I
apologize one second please
okay I think we're back
we're going to forty
one please go ahead
one two forty one you are open
-- trialing to fifty five
okay ladies down once again
at this time would you please
press one followed by zero
if you'd like to queue up
I'll try to forty one
-- line one ninety two
please go ahead europen
Committee I know do we think
we are the building and
this is not that you need
thank you can please go ahead
your line is open to
ten please on real
if you're open to ten go ahead
we can hear you well I am I
to tell yes I wasn't given
a number but okay I'll speak
yes Sir or madam I oppose
this bill although it's very
unclear to most of the people
listening of what this guy
just said ma'am can you hold
on so we're just we're taking
support right now and then
we're going to take opposition
testimony part in just a moment
so I'm looking right now for
support for SB six six zero
and we'll get you in just a
minute the moderator Q.
of okay fine folks that -- to
just state stay tuned at that
were disappointed hearing we're
going to do support side and
we're going to opposition and
that's going to the practices
that we follow here so if
you'd like to speak in support
of SB six six zero please so
indicate and want one more
reminder which is that we
still have to hear another
bill after this SB six six
three but we're not there yet
we're had six six zero so --
if you have an opinion about
six six three hold it hold on
to it and we'll get you in a
couple minutes so a moderator
support for SB six six zero
thank you Mister chair and
as he said please press one
followed by zero first support
only on SB six six zero thank
you and we will go to line
two fifty five please go ahead
two fifty five you are open
two fifty five please on
your phone your line is open
we're going to fourteen
please go ahead
one of those days
what do fourteen
please go ahead
thank you we hear you
to fourteen please hi my
name Alexander from Orange
County California and I
The Great
we'll go to line two sixty two
two sixty two you are open
please on mute hello your
there you go are you can you
hear me it might to sixty two
you're too sick please go ahead
why I'm actually calling
in opposition that six six
three so I am still waiting
okay okay one more final
reminder for support only on
SB six six zero please press
one followed by zero support
only please press one zero
and one more issue sure
we have one queuing up
thank
it was just one second
there with the operator
and we'll go to
line sixty one --
sixty one please go ahead
hi I am box from California
on the bill County I support
the bill it SB six sixty up
thank you
Mr sure there are no other
participants queued up at this
time Kay thank you moderator
and thank you for all your good
work today and no this isn't
always easy we appreciate you
and all the other folks on the
technical side that are doing
their best work to help us
hear from people throughout the
state okay so we're going to
shoot that thank you -- so we
are now going to go to those
who want to speak in opposition
to SB six six zero opposition
-- it so -- moderator I'm gonna
look here first in thirty one
ninety one is or anyone we do
have a a couple of people here
in thirty one ninety one with
the fight you to the microphone
wanted to time -- that are
in opposition to S.
B. six six zero again because
we don't have lead witnesses
were going to give you some
extra time so please go ahead
thank you Mister chairman
honorable senators -- my
name is Warren Heatley and I
oppose prop the -- this bill
six sixty because it flies
in the face of the California
voters who was prop twenty
two -- voiced their opinion
regarding the independent
contractors and this would
this would be just another
attack at the independent
contractor and their ability
to conduct business in
California rific thank you
very much will invite the
other witness to come forward
-- stern said we do have
extra time available within
our limits you can go beyond
your name and affiliation and
share your thoughts with us
the committee hi -- my name
is Shannon Heil and I oppose
this bill because it makes no
difference between if someone's
making -- money per signature
or per hour and it is likely
he said with prop twenty two
it is harming more people who
are self employed and trying
to make a difference here in
California it is greatly a huge
deal an impact to any recall
that you have to have people
who are helping with paper
Titian's regardless if they get
paid hourly or they get paid
power signature there is no
difference they're doing the
same amount of work and they're
working just as hard that's
what thank you so much is there
anyone else here in room thirty
one ninety one that would like
to testify in opposition to
SB six six zero ma'am welcome
hello good morning -- my name
is Stephanie suelen I resign
here in Sacramento county aye
opposed desk -- not only due
to the fact that this is the
freedom of the people that you
guys want to change the bill
to hourly yeah that might work
but I don't think you need to
take it away -- it's just I
oppose it I don't think it's
appropriate people need to
work AB five has killed so many
people already in the state --
it's miserable I think you guys
are only making it miserable
by our policy by proposing
these kind of bills thank you
very much ma'am anyone else
in room thirty one ninety one
hello Sir thank you thank
you all for your patience to
welcome you and please share
your testimony yes I would like
to oppose this bill this bill
is -- very bad for the people
that wants to work out then
work you guys have never been
out that maybe not you but you
may not be familiar Fong help
people because of that and his
stance on the sunlight outside
this dollars asking people
for signatures dealing with
people The sometimes out of
raising them because they are
and they're trying to make a
living this is going to change
the make it more difficult
for anybody to work you're
a jobs are to bring a better
life for the people not to
make it more difficult let's
leave the political outside and
try to focus on what is more
important as I'm driving to
Sacramento right outside your
dollars within a block I see
people sleeping on the streets
is that sad it is very sad
for me please try to sum up
now if you will so I would
appreciate if you take a
consideration that the people
needs more freedom to water
and less restrictions thank
you for your thank you Sir
thank you so much okay so
now that we've exhausted the
three minutes a little bit
more than that -- for lead
witnesses we're not just gonna
ask folks to give their name
and affiliation and their
position on the bill anyone
else here in room thirty one
ninety one wish to testify art
scene and we're gonna go to the
teleconference lines moderator
would you invite those who
like to speak in opposition
SB six six zero to please so
indicate and again we're asking
just your name and affiliation
and position on the bill
thank you very much Mr
chairman and that again if
you're in opposition only to
SB six six zero please press
one zero at this time we'll
start out today -- with line
one twenty please go ahead
I'm so sorry I was going to one
one twenty four please go ahead
I want twenty four you are open
are you muted line
one twenty four
well thanks will try a white
one twenty nine please go ahead
one twenty nine yes can
you hear me yes go ahead
man but I don't think
this is actually a quite
calling from San Matteo county
and I'm in opposition SB six
thank you thank you thank you
one one fifty two please go at
I am I won five
two please on mute
why one sixty four
please go ahead
I want sixty four
hi can you hear me we can
hear you ma'am please go ahead
I'm sorry Armenian okay Page
any girl on Trumka Matteo
Connie and I hope hold on
SB six six zero thank you
thank you next caller please
moderator thank you and we'll
go to line one sixty eight
Justin masters pastor Kelly
thank you will go to
line one seventy four
hi this is a demonstration
with them Benito County I am
opposed to the mail zero all
the restated by the people in
thank you thank you so much
why one eighty five
please go ahead
hello my name is Karen l¯ng
I'm from plaster county and
I am opposed to SB six sixty
nine one eighteen you are open
hi Karen reed -- -- plan
with the county and I'm
opposed to SB six six zero
one one twenty six -- will go
on one twenty please go ahead
hello you are open one
twenty every we can hear
you I don't think he changed
my number sorry I'm oppose
my name's Randy sustain
and I'm in Ventura county
California I'm an individual
thank you we'll go to line
one twenty six please go
ahead hi Committee holidays
kind of Clara County
aye opposed six six zero
thank you one fifty
nine you are open
people
please go ahead one fifty nine
at U. S. I thank you can
you from plaster county
and I would be a nearly
oppose this bill thank you
by one seventy one
please go ahead
I am very along Santa
Clara county and I
oppose SB six six zero
next we're gonna go to line
one eighty nine please go ahead
hi this is that Debra cash
Ventura county -- at peak work
is a time honored -- profession
and what is your name your
cabinet just your name at the
thank you thank you okay there
we will go to line two ten
my name is Diane Sutton from
Ventura county California
nine oppose SB six six zero
thank you one two fifty one
you are open please go ahead
hi yes my name is heather
hi all I am a resident of
Sacramento county and I
strongly oppose this bill
thank you thank you and
like to sixty one Europe
good morning manage what
Muhammad the California chamber
of commerce we respectfully
oppose this bill thank
thank you I want seventy
two please go ahead
hi occurs underground
intercounty I oppose this bill
my to sixty two your open can
you hear me we can hear you
hello hello my name's Chris
Griffin Santa Clara County
small business owner contractor
and I oppose this bill
thank you lane to sixty
nine please go ahead
my name is Rebecca Garcia from
better County I am opposed
to bill number six six three
thank you why one forty eighth
please go ahead we are only
taking opposition to bill
six six zero as a reminder
at this time opposition
to SB six six zero only
please thank you and we'll
go to line one forty eight
right yes you hear me we on
the Silicon Valley and aye
opposed six sixty California's
already stomping on the
rights of Americans to work
thank you and we will
go to line -- one fifty
two please go ahead
it took themselves out
let's try line one twenty
eight please go ahead
I twenty please on mute
laughter County in opposition
I am thirty five
please go ahead
hi this is Gloria Mathis
you never interact County
animal clothes on SB six
six zero thank you thank you
one forty please go ahead
thank forty please on mute
forty would you your all time
-- one last some
plaster county L.
I. opposed SB six six zero
thank you and we will go
to line one hundred and
fifty two please go ahead
what we can't hear you please
go ahead hi this is bad
from Santa Clara county -- I
strongly oppose SB six will
thank you and we'll go to
line two hundred thirty
seven please go ahead
hi this is telling that
person I represent Act
Monterey Bay and I strongly
oppose six six zero
right forty five
please go ahead
hello welcome thank you County
approach six zero thank you
line forty seven you are your
line is open Roberts with major
challenges go California I
oppose SB six six zero thank
you Sir we'll go to line
fifty two please go ahead
thank you to you are
open please on mute
S. U. okay number well
because yolo county I
oppose SB six six three that
okay we will go to line one
forty three please go ahead
hi this is Dennis Beatty from
Fairfield California clapper
says get a clarification did
Senate senator Newman say
he has experienced a recall
themselves in the second thing
is I I do not support -- SB
six sixty if you could please
clarify that he experienced
-- recall himself thank
thank you will invite him to
address it if he wishes in
his clothes thank you very of
the call next caller please
okay thank you Mister chair
and we wanted to seventy two
please go ahead yes this is
Turner -- Santa Clara county
and I oppose six six zero
and will be I would
like thirty seven
Orange County I -- approach
big big big thank you I won
fifty four please go ahead
Tom Goldman analysts misspoke
County I oppose SB six sixty
another attack in Korean a
prize and private contractors
X. will align fifty seven
fifty seven please on you
if you'd like to speak
but will move to line a one
twenty four please go ahead
I'll gallery apple bottom from
Lafayette Contra Costa county
and I at eight six six zero
thank you one sixty
senators is a store rose on
behalf of the legal would
be better to California we
are very respectful of the
opposition thank you thank
you line one -- skews me line
sixty nine please go ahead
hello one the backyard
I oppose SB six six zero
thank you line
seventy you're open
one payment Orange County
and I oppose SB six six zero
thank you live seventy
five please go ahead
I don't have any Low cemetery
county Idaho six six zero
thank you thank you line
eighty seven who are open
good morning my name is
Sharon Paisley from riverside
county and I strongly oppose
SB six six zero thank you
thank you one sixty
to please go ahead
San Benito County
oppose six sixty
thank you eighty
please go ahead
in line up remember that
when we were doing it to
eighty please go ahead
two eighty what was that
eighty nine -- I'm sorry eighty
nine my name is Susan Abbott
I'm from the city and county
princes go and I strongly
oppose six six zero I hope
you take into account the
following evening thank you
very much about how many other
callers we have been Q.
it looks like a bomb or get
down there one two three but
seven okay very governor's
disk please continue thank you
again for all your good work
thank you and we will my one
sixty four please go ahead
just a couple more cued up
by the way store at red rock
Chen on this year -- all one
one sixty four hi my name is
Gail just wondering if that
lady number one ninety two is
already inside of the building
if you can let them in that
would be great thank you
thank you next caller please
and Waldron SB six thank you
not a writer next caller place
yeah we'll go to line two
oh eight please go ahead
and they took themselves argue
I two seventy please go ahead
I have not heard any ago
and I drum lamp post SB
six six eight thank you
one seventy eight
you are open seventy eight
please on mute
five seventy eight
I will would you like to
speak lives seventy eight
your open
at responding will trial a one
sixty eight please go ahead
Sir with a limit on the
number of people that can
to be in the hearing room
but we're taking all callers
on the teleconference lines
thank you for for calling
and we will go to
line two twenty six
like to twenty six
and no response amateur
there's nobody else queued
up at this time all right
terrific well thank you again
-- moderator for your good work
and for everyone's patience
-- we're gonna now bring the
-- to to heard from support
in opposition witnesses and
those testifying here in the
capital as well as on the
teleconference line going to
bring the matter back to the
committee for further comments
and and questions center Newman
anything you want to -- add
to -- -- the comments that you
heard thus far AB be surely
missed your show is so good
that the when the colors as
if I had persons transfer the
recall I think those who are
familiar California politics
not know that I have -- but
let me see very clearly I I'm
actually did serve despite that
experience -- a firm believer
-- in these constitutional
tools vertically when used
appropriately and when used
honestly up to some of the
witnesses who have spoken --
in reference to eighty five
I actually do appreciate that
concern -- but I I would point
out that that's what we're
in different to do here is
not to prevent anybody from
working -- it is it is not to
change A. N. N. A.
center gathers relationship
to their employer I think
that's a very separate set of
questions as it relates to --
independent contracting what we
are trying to do is to remove
the incentive to expedite
the gathered signatures at
the expense of the truth --
and I think in particular and
local initiatives that are
funded by outside groups that
is a common observation that
professional signature gathers
in in sort of their diligent
work to maximize their hourly
return are sometimes less than
ethical less than clear in
the representations there's
nothing about this bill that
would prevent a signature
gathering operation from
paying the people who they've
engaged to collect signatures
-- and I think that's that's
important to note that having
said that -- what we want in
our initiative process is the
assurance that if and when a
measure reaches the threshold
to qualify for the ballot that
that that is done honestly and
in so doing that represents the
sentiment the true sentiment
of the voters I and as such it
does the work that the framers
intended which is to validate
the the legitimacy -- and
the import of the the action
being taken those things that
run counter to that -- tend
to corrode our faith in these
processes -- and so that's my
goal here is not to restrict
in any way -- the public or
any particular groups right
to exercise -- these tools
but to ensure when they are
employed -- that the public
in each voter that is campus
has the assurance that they're
participating in an honest open
and ethical process that's to
the good for our our state for
our democracy for a politics
-- five other states have
implemented laws very similar
to this again it does not
prevent signature gathers from
being pages not prevent groups
from paying their signature
gathers what it does do is is
align incentives with ethical
behavior -- and with that
I respectfully ask your aye
vote today thank you senator
Newman -- I've appreciated the
conversations that we've had
-- offline on on this issue
and certainly -- going through
what you have gone through
I appreciate -- how -- it
important the integrity of this
process says and I know that
we're going to hear another
bill in a few minutes about
the recall petition -- which I
think for me at least is headed
and they were in the right
direction for trying to deal
with that some of the concerns
that you raise and none of us
want to see this representation
-- with that yeah for me at
least it we assume that per
provisions that are in our laws
that that -- allow for someone
to be prosecuted for for
Mississippi and misleading and
what they do and the dilemma
for me is that while we share
the same aims -- I I think that
at the end of the day that the
this measure is going to raise
the cost and create greater
barriers to qualify measures
and that I think that's why
that's why three previous
governors at that cited to veto
similar bills to this and --
also the the fact that there's
a private right of action here
creates a lot of concern for me
of creating a an incentive on
the opposite side someone who
sees a personal profit to --
to prosecute cases that would
be allowed under this bill also
for me as troubling and and Y.
reluctantly I'm not gonna be
able to support it today -- but
I appreciate all the good work
that you have put in this area
and I know and a moment we're
going to hear another bill that
I think it tries to advance
some of the goals that you have
to establish I do know that
-- are Committee short is that
members are in other committees
with other obligations and
so I guess what I would ask
is to hold this -- as we wait
for other members to join and
we'll see if there's a motion
to -- to advance this -- in
a few minutes okay with that
certainly anything you wanna
St close when I make sure you
get that opportunity I I want
to just touch on on your point
regarding the private right of
action -- and yeah you know I
appreciate the kind of the red
flag that that tends to rage at
but I will say in not just my
experience but the experience
of of of of many recall efforts
at where a patient you guys
might not have been -- you know
so fully ethical there is a
dilemma and it's it's already
as you I think alluded to it's
already expressly illegal to
to intention mislead a voter as
to the nature intent of issues
you're getting process but as
it turns out there's there's
virtually no possibility of
enforcement -- as a practical
matter -- day in it you know
it's not surprising when you
think about it so we give
great latitude free speech
I in the conduct of politics
the problem more importantly
most of those who would be
-- charged with enforcing --
that particular statute are
themselves political actors are
themselves subject to elections
I and so they're they're very
disinclined to take steps
even when -- sort of important
to do so -- and so the you
know so that's the basis for
that effort but they're also
problems with admissibility of
evidence that as it turns out
you you could if you recorded
a signature gather on on your
cell phone -- making a clear
reference misrepresentation
that evidence indicate Uniserve
standard coffee prices would
not be admissible in court
I into it creates a catch
twenty two where if you know
practitioners of six you got
and are willing to bend the law
there's very little recourse
under current law despite the
nominal -- probation on the
misdemeanor penalty so it so
that's the basis for that --
again to be clear -- you know
these are all very useful tools
what we're trying to do is to
strengthen them -- and into
your your concern I think it's
it's a it's a concern shared
by others as to whether not
this might raise the cost of
of -- do you know serve these
sorts of efforts -- I'm not
sure that's clear -- but I
would say that that we do want
the assurance that that people
participating in these clips
across these are properly --
-- -- informed -- and so if you
work for instance -- trying to
serious popular support that
would be a kind of any material
can concerns right because you
would have no shortage of you
know volunteers Energy we've
seen that quite recently -- but
in those cases where there's
a used a moneyed interest it
actually works completely in
their favor -- and and against
perhaps in some cases the
interest of other less -- you
know Shiv -- well endowed I
constituencies because if you
have six million dollars or
let's go the other way if you
have an initiative you want to
bring to the ballot -- and you
talk to a a signature gathering
firm they tell you what the
going price might be and say
you need to gather the million
six of signatures and it's it's
it's they give the going rate
is five dollars for a signature
well you know progress eight
million dollars if you have a
million dollars it's basically
a done deal right would you
know that the market when
working officially you'll get
those strangers if you can
pay for them in in many cases
that you don't even have to do
it -- as we are taking to the
recent bill and privacy simply
the threat to do so it's enough
to compel the Legislature into
action and compromised that's
clearly counter to what the
original framers intended by
way of these tools so that you
know there's there's always
another side but I wanted in
this case that this is all on
balance to the good -- and my
hope is that it will be support
today that thank you senator
Newman and I think you make a
very good point -- in regard
to the enforcement question
and it goes beyond this issue
two other issues of -- of
where we put private right
of action and other places in
our in our codes -- because
of a lack of confidence that
our public law enforcement
community which were has direct
line responsibility and as
proposed in your bill and other
places -- have not stepped up
as they should and he raise a
number of issues that I think
are legitimate -- issues in
that space and I wanna I wanna
make knowledge that I would
note that -- the petition
process is simply one part
of the -- if you will action
process that the end of the day
the voters -- if L.
one was successful -- would
still have to provide their
judgment and that we do know
that you know how the money
can influence that process
to I guess I have from my own
experience I would say that
if you have a a a and a deep
pocket financial interests
that they're gonna be a lot
easier for them to pay someone
-- by the hour -- and afford
that versus for the signature
than some other interest that
maybe not as as well funded I
appreciate that there can be
reasonable -- the people on all
sides of that question it's not
an easy one to unnecessarily
prudent -- certainly it it's
at the heart of the that you
feel is the disincentive for
things to be done right and
I appreciate that and -- and
appreciate the expertise he
experiences that you have that
are -- that deep and meaningful
and I think -- -- provide your
leadership in this space and
I admired and respected okay
with that without that scene
if there's any other colleagues
who wish to make a comment
about this I don't see any
hands going up I think we're
going to do on this is just
a for it for a few minutes to
wait for members to come back
into Committee and see where
they want to they want to take
it all right so with that we're
just gonna put that one on
hold that was SB six six zero
-- and -- we're gonna move on
on our agenda item number six
hi this is a legislation by
a friend of this committee
senator Newman -- and it is a
different numbers of those who
are paying attention please
do so now this is SB six six
three is a lot of excitement
early in the hearing and this
may be a moment to -- to step
up and and share your views on
that as we hear this bill so
senate-room and we welcome your
comments on SB six six three
thank you Mister chair -- I
diss the bill the S. B.
six six three which apparently
has instigated so much interest
-- I am here before you to
advocate on its behalf SB
six six three will protect
the integrity California's
current constitution able
processes for recalling a state
elected space sitting alike
that official by addressing a
deterring unethical practices
in the collection of signatures
toward qualifying the recall
effort by allowing the target
of that ever the opportunity
to communicate directly with
voters whose signatures may
have been fraudulently or
misleadingly secured as part
of an effort as noted in my
earlier testimony California is
one of a number of states whose
constitutions express revived
the public to have recourse
to directly redress abuse of
government or malfeasance by
public officials in the form of
the initiative the referendum
in the recall this bills deal
specifically and exclusively
with the recall process and I
will point out at the outset
this bill has no urgency
provision if signed into law
it will not go into effect
until next year as such it
will have no impact whatsoever
on the current recall effort
against governor Newsom voters
signed petitions protecting
the high traffic locations were
professional singers together
set up rarely take the time
to read the actual text of a
petition instead rely quite
often upon the representations
of the signature gatherers
this means you surgery gathers
often operate without any
sort of transparency routinely
and systematically misleading
voters about not only the
rationale but the process and
with little if any concern
about legal repercussions the
current law allows for voters
to withdraw their signatures
from recall petition the
success withdrawal seizures is
for all intents and purposes
largely impossible for most
voters for two primary reasons
first request for signature
withdrawals must be received
by elections officials before
the signature is submitted
to election officials for
validation yet the voter is
rarely if ever aware of when
the petition signatures will
be submitted as and they are
often done on a rolling basis
second once a recall petition
has been signed in process to
voter has no practical way of
finding out whether he or she
might have been deceived into
signing a petition because
no one other than elections
officials not even the target
of a recall effort is currently
permitted under existing law
to inspect the signatures
or the names on a particular
petition as a consequence the
target recall even where there
is clear evidence of unethical
activity in the collection
of those signatures is it an
immense an unfair disadvantage
in trying to offset that effort
and to prevent the proponents
of the of the opportunity to
reach the prescribed number
of qualifying signatures by
canvassing petition signers and
asking them to rescind their
signatures from particular
recall petitions if they
have been misinformed SB six
six three would provide the
target recall petition the
very very closely circumcised
opportunity to examine
submitted signatures while the
liberal establishing guardrails
around how the target recall
may use information obtained
for the petition transparency
measure adopted through
this bill As sharpened by
the amendments proposed by
committee staff under the
transit SB six six three the
target of a recall effort will
be limited to using petitions
singer information only to
win sure the voters understood
the petition when they signed
it and doing the support
the goals of the petition if
orders include they've been
deceived into signing SB six
six three that provides a
pathway and a time line to
assist voters in withdrawing
their signatures the opposition
will assert that making the
allowance for the target of
a recall effort to counter
petition those who assigned
to somehow and violation of
the signers privacy and would
leave them vulnerable to
ration and retaliation not only
do the amendments and other
provisions ensure that this
won't happen it's also true
that the overall rationale the
original restaurant rationale
for restricting access to reap
recall petition actually had
nothing to do with insulating
a target from its target
rather these provisions were
intended to prevent subsequent
misuse of the petition and
its information by others
whose aims were unrelated
to the original effort under
the logic of the framers of
California's recall process
and ever to remove a sitting
elected official to recall
was meant to be something of a
trial by ballot if you will it
is a fundamental tenet of the
American justice system that
the accused should always have
the right to face his or her
accusers this is what we're
endeavoring to do nothing more
nothing less than that to that
end California petition process
should be respected honest and
provide voters with confidence
that their seizures do not
result from nor contribute
to the misrepresentation
distortion of the basis on
which the recall from office
is currently being sought if
the means by which features a
collective qualifying are less
than ethical it undermines
the validity of the recall
effort and brings into question
the value of the signatures
gathered in the conduct of that
effort providing the target of
the recall with the opportunity
to communicate with petition
signers seem reasonable
and fair while respecting
and protecting the signers
including for retaliation
and that's more than just
by considering the serious
implications of a recall
effort I would like to thank
the committee Ste you with my
staff to draft amendments to
protect the privacy of signers
and defined the terms on which
these sorts of process will
take place with that would also
prohibit disclosure of personal
information a prior require
of ages and expressly prohibit
any kind of retaliation
by the target of a recall
I am respected X.
respectfully asking for an
aye vote today -- and let
me once again say because I
think it's necessary given
kind of the nature of the
interest in this bill This
bill anomaly has nothing to
do with the current effort
directed against our governor
I will also say this bill is
not to be relevant to those
efforts aye aye will accord
-- the organizers of that
effort all the respect is due
because they have been nothing
if not direct and honest
with the people of California
anybody who is signed it their
petition probably has a very
clear understanding as to
what they're asking and why
and in this case did not to
take the role of the aims of
my bill my bill actually it's
good aspires to address the
other scenario in which the
terms recall are not properly
represented to the signers --
and as such the target recall
should have recourse to at
least ascertain whether not
voters understood what they
were signing particularly given
the eight the implications
to that elected officials
career and the relationship
to the voters thank you Mr
Jerry good thank you senator
Newman as I understand it we
don't have lead witnesses in
support or in opposition so
will allow some discretion
at the start to -- -- for
both sides to have -- those
individuals who are speaking
to provide a little bit more
context to their opinions and
their position so first that
we're gonna ask for those who
like to speak up in support
of SB six six three that
are here in the room thirty
one ninety one of the state
capitol to please so indicate
I see no hands up here sort
of this is in support okay
so we're gonna now go to
the telephone lines -- for
-- moderator for opera --
individuals would like to
speak up in support of SB six
six three if you could ask
them to please so indicate
welcome them to our hearing
thank you very much
and again to show your
support for a bill S.
six six three SB six six three
please press one zero at this
time and we'll go to line one
twenty eight please go ahead
I'm again my name is Elaine
bash for non in a county where
we're not doing opposition yet
we're doing support through
it what we will do that
incorrectly sorry we'll get
you a penny you'll get a chance
but okay I want to just remind
again we are very committed to
fairness years so we're given
twenty minutes on each side and
we have a time keeper to make
sure we're doing that that so
we want to make sure we do that
everybody in their in their
categories support first twenty
minutes and then opposition
-- twenty minutes so that's
what we're trying to keep it a
little look well organized if
we cancel moderator asked folks
who want to speak up in favor
in favor of SB six six three
two to join our hearing now
thank you very much Mister
chair we'll go to line one
forty one SB six six three
in favor please thank you
good morning Mr chairman
members bond rap on behalf
of the California faculty
association speaking in
support of SB six six three
thank you thank you Y.
Y. one hundred eighty
eight please go ahead
one eighty eight
who
was on the line last year
okay he said hi I've been
one zero to get it up you
want to speak one eight eight
one one ninety two -- go
ahead hello this is in
favor Eloise instead in
favor of SB six six three
in favor only right now but
well move on we're gonna
go to line one ninety
two please go ahead
what ninety two you're open
you okay -- why two forty seven
and as a reminder please if
you are in favor of SB six six
three please press one zero L.
over two forty seven
good morning Chen members my
name is Chris stop mayor and
I am calling on behalf of the
American federation of state
county and municipal employees
in support of S. B.
X. three thank you thank you
thank you my to sixty nine
okay please go ahead thanks I
have to be put back in queue
thank you okay thank you
really do in support right now
do opposition in just a moment
support for S. B.
six six three go ahead
moderator eight thank you
and we will go to a two
eighty seven please go ahead
we'll be back in the line
there's no other participants
queued up at this time all
right let's look here and
I'll call final call for those
who want to speak in favor
in favor of SB six six three
last that last call operator
anyone else and in the queue
nobody is queuing up please
I'll give you a not will give
a warmer chance please press
one zero if you want to show
that your support of SB six
six three please go ahead
I nobody's queuing up okay
terrific all right so let's go
down to opposition to SB six
six three will begin here in
room thirty one ninety one in
opposition I see a few hands
so -- I'll let testimony go
for three minutes so you're
welcome to say more than just
your name and understand that
it's collectively three minutes
so Sir your you're welcome
to come on up and share your
thoughts thank you thank you
Mister chairman honorable
senators and Mister Newman aye
-- move no personal disrespect
okay I'm take I am -- or and
Heatley I am a resident of
Sacramento county and I am
in strong opposition to this
bill for many reasons I am the
lead proponent for the largest
ever attempted petition drive
in our nation's history okay
and I worked the streets I
gathered signatures I talked
were afraid to participate
and the petition gathering
process because they were
afraid their personal private
information would be disclosed
to the target and self and
they actually would walk away
from the tables -- and turn
away from participating in
the lawful peaceful petition
gathering process their first
amendment right because they're
afraid of retaliation and
retribution this is a dangerous
and reckless bill that would
give the target of a recall
access to all of that data all
that personal information and
it would stifle the process
that the constitutional process
that people are guaranteed
it would disenfranchise the
voters of the state and -- it
would basically just notify
the petition gathering process
for recalls as a whole so
there's there's a reason that
-- you know in California the
California constitution section
seven article two says that
voting has to be secret okay
and you know why it has to be
secret because you don't want
to allow undue influence on
the population with the with
the political figures right and
then -- you have -- government
code sixty five three that
says that signatures need
to be private kept private
on the petition gathering
process even I can't look at
signatures after they've been
put on the petition okay those
are taken away and this bill
would open up the signatures
and the personal information
for the people that signed
it to a third party because
just the target isn't the only
one who's gonna be looking
at this data and information
they're gonna have an entire
crew if you're gonna campus
over two million signatures
then there's an entire crew
and the likelihood of that
information being leaked out
business owners and you know
personal information things
like that being leaked out into
the public it just expands that
danger it's reckless and it's
a dangerous bill and Mister
Newman I would personally
requested to withdraw very
good thank you Sir very much
that was a full three minutes
-- there so we're going to
ask those who -- testify
now subsequently to just
provide their name and their
affiliation and their position
on the bill so we're gonna
invite anyone else here in
thirty one ninety one to tend
to -- testify in opposition
to SB six six three to please
so indicate now welcome hello
again good morning my name is
Stephanie swell up I am the
lead coordinator for Sacramento
county on that we call Gavin
twenty twenty I will completely
tell you this is a breach on my
voter mandrake your kiss your
position on the bill okay I it
was very good thank you so much
we've already heard that I want
you to look on page three just
really quickly please it says
to assist registered voters
why okay man thank you thank
you I think your position is
is a noun or anyone else here
in thirty one ninety one want
to put their name on the record
in opposition ma'am welcome
my name is Shannon Heil and
I was the lead in Sacramento
for the recall and I oppose
this because the voters the
people they were way more
knowledgeable they were giving
them credit for and also this
is their privacy people were
terrified terrified to sign
this because they didn't want
new some to Nói I think and
that is area thank when this is
our policy and when these are
people guys okay I think it I
think your point was that is
made and I think the previous
speaker made the point as
well if you guys so please you
please be respectful of our
rules okay we want to be fair
and we want to be here before
but I had to come here thank
you thank you for coming here
anyone else here in thirty
one ninety one want to put
their name and affiliation on
the record on this bill and
we're very appreciative of
you being here but we want to
try to be fair and how we're
working this out I'm on all
sides okay Sir welcome thank
you our honorable senators
Assembly Lindy is it tells me
that my privacy is going away
if you could just put your your
name and your affiliation a
position on the bill certainly
with our respect N.
I respectfully this is nothing
against you I know that you are
trying to do the best for us I
guarantee you this girls into
law I I know you have strong
realizing you're welcome to
share them with the committee
and writing hello after hearing
that you know we're gonna be
fair on all sides so little
respect as you could put your
name on the record if you want
to you don't have to I will
ask you to please with broad
this so that's in opposition
to six six three thank you
Sir thank you very much thank
you or anyone else here in
room thirty one ninety one
okay so now we're gonna go to
the phone lines -- moderator
we're looking for those who
want to put their name and
affiliation and opposition
to SB six six three on the
record if you could go ahead
and and -- queue up the debt
the callers there so indicate
thank you very much we will go
to SB six six three for almost
participant in opposition
only please and we will go
our first -- why will be line
two zero two please go ahead
hello my name is Wendy Jones
I'm from El Dorado County SB
six six three is an invasion
of privacy and I emphatically
oppose it okay very good next
caller please enter I want
to remind people that we want
to get as many people on the
record as we can and if you
speak beyond the position
that you have on the bill
you're going to interfere
with their right to put
their name on the record kids
who want to give them that
chance go ahead moderator
thank you much will go to
line one hundred seventy one
I know what I want from Santa
Clara county I immensely SB
six six three we are not in
communist China do not go out
to the next caller yeah and
you don't get okay like to
that okay fair enough we'll
go to line two to ninety two
please go ahead hi my name is
Jacquelyn mystery to imposter
county and I strongly oppose
this bill I have read the
fear about Robert Mugabe Bob
way we will go to like to
seventy five thank you you
two seventy five you are open
would you like to
buy and opposition
what will go ahead go to
decline to sixty eight
Mister is Democrat and -- the
site County resident -- in
strong opposition thank you
bye to seventy please go ahead
two seventy your open
I two seventy your line
is open we can hear you
we hear you yes sorry I
didn't get number if need
from any ago and I strongly
oppose this crazy girl six
sixty three thank you I
twenty four please go ahead
hi this is genet Evan I'm from
Marin county and I represent
a group called moderate moving
more and more work and we are
in strong opposition of bill
SB six six three thank you
thank you one fifty
please go ahead
hello my name is Ruth Weiss and
I'm here to read the through
the the stock opposition to
the bill from the election
integrity project California
real good line one sixty four
you are open
please on mute once your thank
you yes -- my name is K.
from terminate Connie and one
of the volunteers for that
in your complete call and I
strongly oppose on this bill
tweet this is crazy could
not be thank you and that
lady one ninety to keep
fighting I'm a fan of yours
I hope you get to build line
eighty four please go ahead
yes can you hear me yes
please go ahead okay yeah
my name is James hall -- I
live in Morgan hill -- County
Assembly hairs found in a
car County and I yeah and we
are closed SB six sixty three
thank you thank you one one
fifty nine your line is open
yeah Platzer Connie finally
oppose this bill some
intimidation of all the signers
next call please one one
forty eight please go ahead
regarding Silicon Valley were
he said that are against all
elections and we strongly
oppose SB six six three
thank you I fifty seven
I fifty seven year open hi
there can you hear me hello yes
thank
hi there this is Matthew
County now based out of Concord
California a member of a group
called patriot the Contra
Costa I am calling into the
and the only vehemently oppose
my vote I'm I'm opposing that
SB six six three thank you
thank you I am I two seventy
two will go to your line
my two seventy two commuters
hello well one two one one
ninety eight please go ahead
one ninety nine you yes
-- taking rain keep from
Calaveras county I strongly
oppose SB six sixty three
thank you I'll line
thirty nine you are open
when led away in
garden Grove strongly
oppose SB six six three
thank you why in one
zero one please go ahead
hello
your open
this is still present eagle
county aye opposed SB six
six three thank you Sir next
caller thank you one one
or one please go ahead our
skews me I was only just open
line one hundred fourteen
okay great question mark what
they don't know what number
you are sold your open one
fourteen please go ahead
you don't know when you
get to talk ma'am ma'am
you you've been given line
one fourteen you are open
what will move on the line to
ninety three please go ahead
two ninety three your own thing
Mister minded all
the callers in Q.
if you can have your -- devices
on on mute so that -- you won't
hear the background noise Annie
there's a delay you'll know
that you're really the one or
asking to testify so go ahead
operator thank you very much
and we will aye one hundred
seventeen please go ahead
one seventeen you are
open please on mute
am I on mute you are okay
all right Adele Leighton from
napa valley and get thank
you for the opportunity to
oppose this terrible bill
six six three thank you thank
you the del thanks caller
please play to fifty thank
you Mister chair proceed
that will go to a two fifty
yes I'm Cindy Custer in San
Diego county I strongly oppose
bill SB six three thank you
why to eighty nine
please go ahead
hello my name is Kelly
on spring burger I'm from
Orange County California
my oppose bills that
click three thank you
thank you and we will vote
next we're gonna go to line
eighty two please go ahead my
name is calling Britain with
California Legislative boys
and we strongly oppose SB six
six three thank you thank you
and we will aye one eighteen
number of County and I strongly
oppose SB six six three
thank you Y. en route to
forty one you are open
hello my name is Stacy Pascal
independent lifelong then
individuals myself and my
husband both oppose this bill
real good line one hundred
twenty eight thank you
please go ahead
you don't meet one
twenty eight all
one twenty eight you are open
one twenty eight hello please
go ahead I oppose this bill
I'm from the San Joaquin
county my name is Elaine
dashboard thank you line
seventy five please go ahead
any loan from an account
County I oppose this bill six
six three thank you thank you
one forty three you are open
I am one forty three
please tell me one forty three
hello please go ahead are you
there we are okay great hi this
is a Dennis Beatty from Solano
county and I speak for hundreds
of residents I oppose six six
three the voter intimidation
bill thank you yeah right you
project your testimony next
next caller please thank you
Mister over like fifty two
hello Kimberly Jones because
yolo county and I strongly
oppose SB six six three
thank you for calling and
next caller please twenty
eight please go ahead
we meant very plaster
county election integrity
project California in strong
opposition thank you ma'am
next caller please what a
one eighty eight you are open
what one eighty eight we
can hear you please go ahead
one eighty eight hello please
go ahead yes I am we walked
and then -- from gold river
Sacramento county in aye
opposed SB eight six six three
I mean six six three sorry
thank you
sixty nine I to sixty nine
please go ahead hello hi
my name is Rebecca Garcia
I'm from better County
and I'd be at Lee oppose
SB six six three
thank you one one forty nine
you were your line is open
by one forty nine
at one forty nine
we will go to line one
oh six please go ahead
hi my name is marina from
San Francisco and I oppose
this communist bill thank you
thank you one fifty nine
please go ahead hello my name
is Jennifer Johnson private
citizens from plaster county
I vehemently oppose SB six
six three thank you nine
fifty nine your open excuse me
line by two can we will go to
this is Diane Sutton from
are a member of the election
integrity project of California
and I oppose SB six six three
we will go to line eighty
nine please go ahead
eighty nine you are open
we can hear you
please hello hello
would you like to
speak eighty nine
eighty nine are you can you
hear me we can hear you now so
go ahead I'm sorry I'm sorry
I didn't know that was the
my number for the previous
one my name is Ann abit I'm
from Justinian County of San
Francisco and aye Thein misli
opposed mis characterization
of signature gathers thank you
three thank you miss out of it
thank you I want sixty eight
one fifty eight please go ahead
Jeff masters like they're
special I am strongly opposed
to Senate bill six six three
thank you Sir next call please
sure what twenty
four please go ahead
hello I am Valerie Applebaum
Lafayette Contra Costa county
I strongly oppose SB six six
three thank you thank you ma'am
we just have a few minutes left
operator how many people in Q.
I'm there's a handful -- I met
all right let's okay at four
four minutes four minutes left
let's get to as many as we can
so go ahead Sir okay okay thank
you actual go to thirty one
line thirty one please go ahead
yes my name is Leslie Krom
from San Francisco -- Senate
bill six six three the violate
our constitutional right
to privacy next one Adeline
to fifty nine please go at
two fifty nine you are open
two fifty nine please go ahead
we'll be along we will close to
hello if you want to speak
go ahead yeah this is going
to look for Pleasant Hill
California Brown's down
this ridiculous bill thank
you I need to four lane
two eighty six are you
going to get to eighty six
will go to next week okay
two eighty six your own thing
we don't mute
we will try line one
eighty five please go ahead
hello my name is Karen
allowing I'm from a voter from
plaster county and I do not
believe any ensure assuring
that given by Mister Newman
thank you Matt next caller
please thank you I won
eighty four you are open
yes hello I just wonder if
they were quickly that the
protocol is unclear and not
user friendly my name is
Sandra Marquez and I represent
the plaster county freedom
coalition and we vehemently
oppose this bill S.
B. six six three thank
you miss Marquess are you
had difficulties with our
protocol so policies for that
thank you for getting your
testimony at next caller please
real good I show you
we will one one seventy
four please go ahead
I was in a car last time so
that me again your your that
you again thank you okay
thank you this is a downturn
that Assembly need a County
live in a small town where we
calling our mayor the R.
sum down to this protocol
because it'll make all this
target and email you cannot
guarantee it allegation from
ground thank think we'll
go to line two twenty five
hello mate yes yes well okay my
name is marina Roach and I am
a concerned -- registered voter
in San Francisco and I strongly
oppose Senate Bill two six
sixty three thank you very much
so we've gone to the twenty
minutes in opposition -- just
allow a couple more callers in
opposition operator the next
three more callers will bonus
time in the opposition side so
bring three more colors
and bouncer Grogan Mister
chair -- the first one of
the three will be like one
fifty three please go ahead
San Luis Obispo county strongly
opposing SB six six three
thank you one to thirty please
go ahead yes this is Michelle
and Carla Kelly in Los Angeles
County I strongly oppose bill
six six three and the many
bodies that them thank you
very much last caller please
yes thank you are last of
personal be like line two
hundred and seventy three
please let yeah M.
Gallagher Sacramento county
aye opposed to opposition SB
six six three thank you so much
and -- moderator again thank
you for your wonderful patients
as we do our work here today
I want to thank all those who
of of come forward to testify
in support and in opposition
to this bill -- appreciate
everyone's patience as we try
to do our work we try to do
it in a fair and balanced way
hope you appreciate that we
are trying to ensure that we
get as much -- information
and testimonies we can as we
hear this bill okay so with
that we're going to close the
public testimony portion of the
hearing and go to my colleagues
on the panel for any questions
or comments Center Leyva thank
you Mr thank you Mister chair
I'm appreciate all of the --
testimony in opposition I heard
-- what people are saying I
know that there are concerns
over privacy but I have to say
is someone who has participated
in signature gathering for
thirty years prior to running
for office -- everyone who
testified against the bill
may have pure intentions but I
can tell you that most of the
people that I have encountered
in those thirty years did not
have pure intentions and -- in
some cases well I mean I let's
just say it when when the you
recall the Mister Newman and
we were when I was knocking
on doors and people said I
didn't know what I was signing
people lie to me people told
me it was about something else
I mean it does happen all the
time -- so I support the bill I
appreciate you bring it forward
and I appreciate the amendments
that you took in order to help
make it a little more a little
cleaner a little more straight
forward and hopefully people
for a little more comfortable
with it but obviously for
the bill now moves that
when it's appropriate
thank you center Leyva any
other comments or questions
from committee members
all right we're gonna and then
now bring it back to center
Newman would you like to close
-- I thank you Mr chairman so
I do appreciate the concerns
articulated by the witnesses
not just here but -- on the
phone as well -- and I want
to speak a little bit of this
notion of privacy rights so
the the ballot in America is
secret -- and that is kind of
a hallowed sacred tradition
but participation in politics
is not intended to be secret
or anonymous and again and
-- I I would point you back
to the intent and thinking
of the original framers of
these measures clearly I mean
that was a different time
and place the only senator
Nielsen was alive at that
time I'm kidding Jim but
but it's it's --
what we're trying to do here is
to create effective deterrence
as much as anything right to
center lowest point and into
my early point I mean I cannot
I will accord the proponents
of this current recall effort
for the full respect the date
that you have been nothing
if not honest and straight
forward with your with your
issue with the folks who had
who US to sign and you know we
have worked with the committee
staff and they've actually been
be extremely thorough on the
the types of amendments taken
in the can of the forms as a
manage would take I and I'm
gonna run down the list really
quickly right and it's it's to
provide exactly the assurance
that I think you're seeking I
on the one hand work which we
exempts small jurisdictions if
the recall target represents a
a a community of of the fewer
than fifty thousand registered
voter that's not population
that voters so it's obviously
much larger out we want to
make sure that that that
that's a small town -- that's
where people might know each
other might be subject to the
kinds of retaliation I think
if you're concerned about --
and so we've created a line to
exempt -- did it communities
below a certain size we we we
will not let people see the
signatures right we do you
know what to do we respect a
person identified information
prevent identity fraud it The
bill prohibits disclosure -- it
prohibits the trying to recall
the represents from sharing
that petitioners goes in the
name of a signer it includes a
number of other recall petition
list protections -- and I won't
go them to now it requires the
use pledge by a recall target
-- and the representatives to
to submit in writing -- upon
a penalty of a misdemeanor
-- that they wanted to use
that information in any form
and again I can I give the
committee credit for working to
live really to create the kinds
assurances that I think people
are speaking to but then again
I will come back to this notion
that you know politics and and
you know public debate is is
inherently Public and that's
not a bad thing I also point
out that is that -- what for
the most part you know there
is this is sort of a paradox
here that -- you you the the
-- opposition looking for Sir
insurance of anonymity privacy
when in fact that many of the
same people are Kinks dreamily
active on social media -- and
extremely public -- and so I
would point out that if the
government California were
interested in retaliating he
be doing so right now it's not
that hard to find -- the you
know the proponents the active
supporters of this measure and
so again what we're trying to
do is to to create a deterrent
structure so that in the event
of a recall effort there is an
incentive to act honorably I
even if that that conversation
is uncomfortable right because
the you know the can that's
in the nature of our politics
not everything's competently
given how divided our culture
society and our state is today
so having said that I am glad
to work with stakeholders here
-- if there are amendments or
or provisions that you think
address your needs please bring
them to me -- because again
what I'm trying to do is not to
stop recalls not to -- inhibit
public debate but to ensure
that these things are done
honestly and with integrity
moving forward so with that
Mister chair I asked when I
go to that thank you senator
Newman center Leyva has an
additional question -- point
to make think thank you sorry
about that -- when you were
talking about people being very
forthright and honest -- with
this recall maybe all of you
in here have been those of you
who identified herself as part
of the recall I just want to
say that my personal experience
was different from that when
the recall first started prior
to the pandemic UP I approached
a couple of different folks
that were gathering signatures
and the line that they were
using is that Gavin Newsom had
raise the gas tax and I said
you know that's not accurate
I said because I was here
when governor brown was the
one who signed that into law
so I just your point senator
Newman people are not always
honest and what I said is
you can you can find this for
make sure you know why you're
signing he did not raise the
gas tax that was the difference
governor thank you thank you
I center Leyva let me let me
just say -- senator Newman I
want to thank you for that the
work that you've done with my
committee staff and with me
on this bill -- as you know I
haven't been a big fan of this
guy scheme that's kind of been
in line places that we have
today but I think what you're
doing and the amendments that
you've taken have really gone
a long way to -- dealing with
a lot of the concerns that I
had certainly as it relates to
privacy and you went through
a number of those -- in detail
so I won't repeat them -- but
they're significant and I think
that it gives a confidence
anyone signing up a petition
that their name will not be
abused -- as it we have similar
rules in place rather --
signatures that are gathered
in in in a similar fashion
let me also mention that one
of the things you didn't know
was another amendment that you
took -- which that -- in and
under current law when you --
advance a petition to remove
someone -- that there is no
highlights to -- anything that
you're doing on that petition
it simply as a paragraph it's
all jumbled together and --
it's very difficult for anybody
being asked to sign it would
understand with clarity what
that petition really intends
to do and it goes to senator
-- labor's point earlier that
you know what am I signing what
is it really do it -- the --
barking from the petition as
signature gather it may not be
my nay not match up with what
exactly they're putting before
that voter and you've taken an
amendment to make it clear at
the top of every page -- that
-- the the who it is exactly
that person that is being
requested to be recall I think
that's a significant amount
as well and for those reasons
it's and it's for those reasons
that I'm at -- going to support
your your bill today so we we
have -- we've gone through the
committee process in an orderly
and fair way -- here -- in the
capital as we do on all bills
and so we've gone through that
process of public testimony
-- extraterrestrials I want to
-- I want to bring a matter of
time I'm gonna bring the matter
up again back to the committee
we're looking for a motion
here I think senator Leyva has
asked it to be recognized at
this point in the proceedings
-- Center Leyva you are moving
this bill do passed but first
re refer to the committee
on judiciary I'm saying that
correctly yeah so we have a
motion before the committee
and will ask the consultant
to please take the role
SB six six three the motion is
to pass the first be referred
to the committee on judiciary
Glazer hi there are you also
Nielsen no Hertzberg Leyva five
Riverside Newman aye Newman aye
okay so that's a bill currently
has enough votes to get apple
we're gonna put it on call for
an absent member all right so
we have a lot of -- they just
review our situation we have
one final bill on the docket
-- and then we have -- bills
on call and one bill that
hasn't that received a motion
yet that still entertain one
-- at that time but for now
I'm gonna turn the gavel over
to my wonderful vice chair
senator Nielsen so -- we can
proceed with the agenda perfect
ready to present Mister
chairman I am ready refocusing
our this is SB six eight
six -- that's what the is
before the committee and
what I'm presenting it would
provide greater transparency
and disclosure for limited
liability companies that make
political contributions -- as
they're known L. L.
C.'s have a limited existing
public disclosure requirements
under the political Reform Act
in other existing laws they are
unlike corporations that have
existing filing requirements
in two thousand nineteen
a fair political practices
commission enforcement division
examination of L.
L. C.'s found that it was
relatively easy to find
information about in L.
L. C.'s type of business it's
address and its agents for
services up process however
it was extremely difficult
and many times impossible to
identify in L. L.
C.'s owner or the true source
of funds for an L.
L. C.'s political expenditures
SB six eight six six to provide
the public with additional
information on L.
L. C.'s that make campaign
contributions specifically this
bill would require L. L.
C.'s to submit to the secretary
of state upon qualifying as
a committee a list of members
who either have a membership
interest in the L.
L. C. of at least ten percent
or made a cumulative capital
contribution of at least a
thousand dollars secondly it
codifies existing F.
PPC regulations focusing on
reporting requirements for L.
L. C.'s and requiring the
disclosure of the person
responsible for the L.
L. C.'s political activity
SB six eight six is sponsored
by the fair political practices
commission on the line to
speak in support and answering
technical questions as Lindsay
Mecano with the F.
PPC Californians deserve
to know who's trying to
influence the political process
this bill is a simple yet
meaningful approach to provide
clarity regarding political
contributions and aims to
disclose the true source
of funds used by L.
L. C.'s and with that I
respectfully ask for your aye
vote thank you Mr chairman
do we have anyone here in
the room to testify Mister
chairman we had a a a a lead
supporter online Lindsay the
kind of with the F.
PPC and -- she's in the room
or on the telephone lines
good faith but she has not
on the line okay please
would you proceed then with
your testimony in support
thank you good morning Mister
chair and senators my name
is Lindsay McConnell and I
am Legislative Council for
the fair political practices
commission the FCC is the state
commission that administers
and enforces the political
Reform Act which regulates
campaign financing conflict
of interest lobbying and
governmental ethics commission
is pleased to offer the very
important bill over the last
couple years the FTTC headcount
increasing instances out these
being used as a vehicle for
dark money in state and local
elections under existing law
LLCs can be formed quickly and
relatively anonymously and to
make critical contributions
in after and there's usually
no way for the public to find
out who's actually funding the
contribution The goal of SB six
eight thank is to address the
lack of transparency I setting
like on the true source of
funds used by LP's that spend
money on political activity
in the state I required this
closure of certain members
of the LLC or other words
disclosure of his fund is
the out of in order to come
to a well thought out and
down policy The Commission
researched and considered a
number of approaches including
the approach taken by the
state of New York which
requires an L. L.
C. that makes a political
contribution or expenditure
in any amounts the following
statement of identity that
difficult to every member
of the Alfie SB six it is a
narrower The New York prosje
and requires the statement of
members only if the L.
L. C. reaches a threshold
level of physical activity that
would already under current
law subject the out of the
regulation under the political
Reform Act as a committee or
committee sponsor SB six eight
six also requires disclosure
of not every member of the
Alfie rather only those who
have a ten percent or greater
membership interest or have
made a cap cumulative capital
contribution to the L.
three thousand dollars or more
within a specified period SB
six eight would also codify
Chiu recent regulations that
increase the information
available about Alfie expense
money on political activity
in the state is regulations
are important steps increasing
transparency in this area
for a loan do not give the
public information about the
true source of funds which
is why this bill is crucial
original purposes of the
political Reform Act was to
establish strong disclosure
laws the public is informed
about the people interests
who are funding campaigns
in the state L. L.
C. should not be a vehicle
for concealing identities
are skirting contribution
limits are requiring
disclosure of an L.
L. C.'s funders when it thank
money for political purposes
SB six eight six strengthened
the state campaign disclosure
lock insures that the public
has the information that they
need to make informed decisions
thank you to the committee
and senators thank you the
league of women voters of
California for their support
and thank you center Glazer
for your leadership on this
important subject thank you
do we have any more testimony
in support here present or
on the life and Q.
five moderator any improve
on this and support
we will go ahead not you
people up if you are in
support of this bill please
press one followed by zero
at this time one followed
by zero human support
they do have one person
queuing up one moment please
-- with operator everybody
else going his one zero please
Mr of the and we'll start out
with wine forty please go ahead
Myers the plaster county I
am in support of this bill
thank you one one
sixty please go ahead
I I think this is me I
transplant presently California
clean money campaign we have
not yet taken official position
but we almost certainly
will support it so hope the
committee will move the bill
thank you thank you one one
sixty eight you are open
thank you one sixty
please go ahead
I'm sorry he was invited
to California and
all right in line to
forty three you are open
one moment please I
think three prompting
one three forty
three please go ahead
three forty three
am I am Committee
yes you are please go
ahead I'm I'm coming
dozens of people waiting
on the line to speak in
opposition to six six three
and the two we cut the line and
Californians waiting to call
the Democratic you silence
the voice of the people
The bill trying to get in
today this week in opposition
to reenter cut cut her off
right I Calderon thank you
and as a final reminder to
speak in opposition please
press one followed by zero
Mister chair -- skews
me quote to lying to
sixty one please go ahead
you are open to sixty one
please on you Hey this is
what Muhammad Cal General
respectfully oppose this
bill thank you thank you
we have one more with an
operator one moment please
the with us one moment
thank you for your patience
I want three forty four
please go ahead your open
hello I strongly oppose
SB six six three and would
appreciate your attention
to that would you identify
yourself please Caroline Landy
Fresno California thank you
thank you one three twenty
nine please go ahead my name
is Donna homes and from the
San Diego county and I am
in opposition to the bill
find my three forty
three year old
by
we're gonna going to seventeen
I am Mister chair there's
no other participants
queued up all right thank
you and do we have anyone
testifying in opposition
any further in opposition
not at this time Mister
chair but what do I just pop
down and we'll go to like
thirty five please go ahead
you more distant Gen sorry
there we go Gloria Massey
here ma'am a number of both
of bill six six three thank
you so much I thank you
by two seventeen please
go ahead hi thank you for
answering name my name is Megan
Miller from Los Angeles and
I strongly oppose SB six six
three it's disgusting thank you
thank you M. line three
forty three please go ahead
I was trying when you wanna let
people tell you what let people
in the building six six three
thank you nine three
forty two please go ahead
and they took themselves out
are there no other participants
at this time all right I thank
you and the senator Glazers
would give us close thank you
center Nielsen -- for people
who wonder whether this is
a really a big deal this
disclosure issue that this
bill presents I in two thousand
nineteen there were two hundred
and fifty three LLCs -- that --
were involved in our elections
two hundred fifty three
that's that's a significant
amount and so all this bill
is asking for is a level of
transparency that equals what
we require of others and --
I think it's something that
-- will bring greater --
integrity to our election
work which is a challenge at
times but I think it's a live
ants the the ball in a good
way and I appreciate your
we have a motion alright
we have a motion to fax and
worse is going to be referred
what's the next Committee
okay all right perfect --
of please call the roll
SB six eight six the motion
is to pass in the first be
referred to the committee
on appropriations Glazer hi
Glazer aye Nielsen no close
enough Hertzberg -- Hertzberg
aye Leyva aye Leyva aye Newman
one of one no not for on call
on call for the call we've got
one more vote could come from
back traffic okay thank you Mr
vice chair all right -- we're
gonna we're gonna get some
up now and and make everybody
aware of where we stand with
the matter so on our agenda all
of them have received motions
except for one so that one
would require motion if you
want to advance it that's item
number five SB six six zero
but let's start at the top well
let's ask the consultant to --
open the role on each of the
items that we have heard let's
start with item number one
which is the consent calendar
up on the consent calendar hurt
Nielsen Nielsen aye Hertzberg
Hertzberg by I that has five
votes is that correct so that
vote is out five zero okay --
will go in the order of the
agenda as we next one up would
be six eight six when we were
still missing a number on that
so let's hold on that one --
item number three SB four four
two if you could call the roll
again three four four to the
voters for here with the chair
and vice chair voting aye
Hertzberg aye Hertzberg aye
so that is a -- that's a five
oh vote get the total so I
know that I that's five oh so
that bill is out and that is
dispensed with K.
next one up is item -- -- Gen
item number four -- SB five
eight three by Newman you could
open the role SB five eight
three the voters three zero
with her voting on Nielsen
Nielsen no Hertzberg Hertzberg
by voters for one all right
that bill is out four to one
-- the next one -- members
item number five SB six six
zero this doesn't have a
motion yet so so center Leyva
has moved the bill and if
the console would call the
roll SB six sixty motion is
to pass but first be referred
to the committee on judiciary
Glazer right now Glazer no
Nielsen Nielsen no Hertzberg
Hertzberg aye Leyva Leyva
hi Newman so we're gonna put
that on call that to to to
to wait for senator Newman
to join us and we can deal
with that one next one up is
item number six SB six six
three -- if the console with
yeah
that's a all the gender we
have one of bills all of
so it will be ready to open
up six six three okay so we're
gonna have a pull out on call
and SB six six three for it
-- an updated vote the console
would call the roll thank you
Steve yeah SB six six three
voters three one with the
terror voting I am the vice
chair voting no Hertzberg
Hertzberg guy get that bill
have everything dispensed with
except for two bills and will
wait for senator Newman to join
us again I think for center
Nielsen Hertzberg I think you
guys are covered on everything
okay so we're gonna pause for a
moment as senator Newton Newman
to come back to committee so
we can finish up our work thank
you all for all your good work
today thanks to the technical
staff Tom our moderator thank
you for all your hard work not
an easy day we appreciate you
very much and -- handing you
Mister care thank you and we'll
invite senator Newman to come
back and join us here -- and
we'll wait for his presence
hi we're gonna call the
Senate committee elections
constitutional and then it's
back to order -- we have to
matter still to be disposed of
-- item number two SB six eight
six and item number five S.
B. six six zero let's begin
with the item number two SB
six eighty six of the console
own please call the roll SB
six eight six the motion is to
pass but first be referred to
the committee on appropriations
the lotus three one with the
chairman and the vice chair now
Newman thank you in five right
that bill is out four to one --
next we have item number five
SB six six zero the console
will call the roll SB six sixty
the motion is to pass but first
be referred to the committee on
judiciary the voters to to with
the chair and vice chair voting
no Newman all right hi well
that's a close one right there
the that bill is out three
to two and I think that does
complete our business today
thank you again everyone who
helped with today's hearing and
with that we stand adjourned